Good morning.
I am... I am alive, unfortunately.
Oh my god.
Those 30 streams are the bane of my existence.
Oh my god, sorry, I forgot to turn this off.
Oh my god, okay.
Give me a second.
Oh my god, right now.
Okay.
I'm not... I'm never a person at 12.30.
Sorry, I've been like... I realize I've been consistently late at 12.30.
But I've also been like, not sleeping early at 12.30.
Which is my fault, honestly.
It is... it is my fault.
I've been consistently late for these streams, for this time slot.
But I've also have not been sleeping at a correct time at this hour, this time slot.
I'm sorry, guys.
Why did I sleep late?
I was just working.
I was just catching up to a lot of work stuff.
And...
And I've just been like, you know...
Just... I don't know what else to say.
I've been trying to catch up to a lot of work stuff.
And I literally... because I was like, you know, answering messages and stuff last night.
To like, some of the build up messages that I've like, left like, rotting.
Not rotting, sorry, I shouldn't use that word.
Left like, in my...
Left like, unanswered for a couple of days in my... in my Discord.
And then, I literally was like, just answering all of them, one by one.
Not all of them, there's still a lot more.
And then, I wake up, and then I received 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 DMs from...
12... 12 DMs from 12 different people.
I woke up.
From like, some of the replies I got from people.
So I'm like, can't wait for another hard day of work today.
Okay.
And like, I have like, server messages too.
Alright.
Okay.
Let me see, sorry, I'm just... just reading.
I'm just...
Reading... reading a message.
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay.
Alright,
there you go.
I have to answer... I have to answer a message real quick.
Sorry, my brain is not working at the moment.
My brain is actually... I'm not a... I'm not a functioning human being.
This time, I'm like, oh my god, what do I do with this?
Oh my god, Time Citizen, breakfast, it's just a cat, multitask, I can barely multitask when I'm a functioning human being.
A little...
You can read?
Unfortunately, yes.
Unfortunately, I can't... I have to be able to read to progress in my life.
Which is very unfortunate.
Alright, give me a... let me boot up... let me boot up Dynasty Warriors today.
I told my manager that I'm finally going to do a long, very long stream of Dynasty Warriors today.
Because I don't want to play this game until like 2026.
And then my manager was like, thank fucking god.
And then he was like, this is the Yakuza of your stream.
And I was like, what do you mean?
Because he was like, because Yakuza is like incredibly long.
And he was like, this is the death sentence of your channel.
And I was like, I was like, what?
Because he was like, you can't keep, you can't keep playing Dynasty Warriors, Derky.
You have, you have to, you have to play...
You have to play other games.
You have to start a new series, Derky.
And I was like, okay.
I'll try to do...
I'll do a long stream today.
So, because like, because, because the game is incredibly long.
And I still haven't yet to finish One Kingdom.
There is a high chance that if I am not close to finishing this fucking game by the end of today.
Of my long stream today.
I, for Wu and Wei, I will move it to Twitch.
For the retirement home of, the retirement home of games.
I'll move Wu and Wei to Twitch and finish Xu on YouTube.
No, I thought it would be over.
What do you mean?
You're still gonna go.
After Xu.
Look, look.
I wanna know.
Okay, I know what happens.
In the storyline of Wu and Wei.
But like, I don't know what happens to me in the storyline of Wu and Wei.
Also, life update.
Oh yeah, Twitch VODs channel is still alive.
I just, I've been so busy.
But I'm gonna, I'm gonna pawn over the VODs channel to one of my staff members.
To like, update the VODs and stuff.
Because they are much more reliable than me, obviously.
Anyway, what was I gonna say?
Oh yeah, not life update, but funny update.
So, one of my friends was asking me if I wanted to join this like, supposedly a VTuber Rivals tournament.
But then I was like, I looked at it and I was like, are you sure?
There's no rules.
But it's because it's hosted by a VTuber.
But I was like, are you sure this is a VTuber tournament?
Because there are no rules against non-VTuber.
And then my friend is not a VTuber who recommended me to join this tournament.
So then I was like, are you sure it is a primarily VTuber tournament?
And then I was looking through it, because I was like, no rank limits.
So like, the thing is, the tournament had zero rank limits.
So the last VTuber tournament I participated in, obviously there was a rank limit to it to make sure it's like, equal or fair.
But like, for this one, they didn't even impose a rank limit.
So I was like, so you could technically bring an entire team of top 500 to this tournament.
But it was, majority of it were VTubers, because I was looking through the teams.
And it has a public list of teams and like, attendees, and you can still sign up.
And... okay.
It was so funny, because I was looking through it, and they're all like, regular teams of like, people I don't recognize.
But they're like, VTubers, and they're like, and I looked through it.
And then, at the last page, there's Luminosity's entire pro roster.
And I was like, bro, you're gonna get so shit on.
There's like, one entire pro team in this random ass, quote unquote, VTuber tournament.
I was like, what the fuck is Luminosity doing here?
It's so fucking deep.
And I was like, scrolling through, and I was like, excuse me?
And I sent it to my friend, I was like, do you know Luminosity is in this tournament?
And obviously my friend was like, what the fuck are they doing here?
Like, first place is...
$600, which means each player gets like, $100 each.
So I was like, the fuck are you doing here?
That's so funny, I was like, oh my god.
So like, here, I'll show you.
Like, literally, like, what is Luminosity doing here?
All of that for $100.
It's like, it's broke.
That's so, oh my god.
I was like, literally, the entire roster, all the other teams were literally just regular people.
Like, who are you?
Why are you here?
Majority said people in this tournament were just VTubers.
They don't even have, it's like their entire pro team.
I see some of these people in rank.
Like, they're pros, they really need them.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But like, how did they find out about this tournament?
I also, so then my friend was like, my friend was like, what the, but they're not, they're like, pros like, they're not that good.
And I was like, bro, you're literally the only top 500 player on your team.
Like, you're, yeah, like, yeah, to you they're not that good.
But you have five other people that have not reached your, have never played in your ELO.
Sure, buddy, sure.
I was like, I just thought it was so, literally, literally, the first three, the three pages are like, VTubers.
It's like, they're like, VTubers.
Luminosity.
So, so I don't know, I don't know if they're, I don't think they're, I don't know, I don't, I have a suspicion that my friend's team might not be first place.
Might not win first place.
I don't know, just like, a suspicion there.
Because they have no other rules.
It's literally no rank limits.
Anyone can join, but it's hosted by a VTuber.
So, like, so it's like, you don't have to be a VTuber to join this tournament.
So you can literally sign up your entire pro fucking team to be part of it.
I don't know, I don't know what tournament it is.
I got, I got asked to join the team and I saw that and I was like, no.
I was like, unless we bring our own fucking one above all team, we are not, I am not fighting Luminosity.
I'm not fucking fighting Luminosity.
Alright, here we go.
I'm booting up Dynasty Warriors.
And the thing is, I found out another, another, like, when I told my friend about Luminosity's joining, one of their team, one of his teammates was like, oh yeah, BlankPerson is also bringing a team.
And I was like, bro, you know that, and I was like, I'm not gonna say who it was, who's, who the person is that they're talking about.
And I was like, but I know who that, like, me and my other friend knows, like, what type of person he is.
And I was like, bro, you know that guy's gonna bring an entire pro roster too.
Good fucking luck, bro.
He's not gonna bring someone below Eternity.
And he's also not a VTuber that's joining that tournament.
I was like, you know that guy's gonna bring entire, like, full roster of Eternity players, man.
Like...
I was like, good fucking luck.
I know, like, the end game is that team and Luminosity.
Alright, let me set my volume up real quick.
Okay, back at it again.
A long day of Dynasty Warriors.
Alright, continue.
Not Doki.
Easy $600.
My second favorite Chinese person?
Who's your first?
Like, what do you mean?
Someone in chat was like, yippee, my second favorite Chinese person.
Alright, let's look at my letters.
I forgot to read my letters.
I skipped all my letters to read a letter from Zhuge Liang.
Alright, let's read my first super chat of the day.
Oh, okay, never mind.
That's not a super chat.
Who cares?
Let's go through my fan mail.
Do not Doki.
Oh wait, I forgot I'm supposed to be left side Doki.
It's been a while, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me bring left side Doki over here.
Where the fuck did I put left side Doki?
It's been so long.
That's not left side.
Oh my god, where is left side Doki?
Did I accidentally delete her?
Oh wait.
Wait, where is she?
Where did she go?
Oh no, guys, left side Doki might be gone.
Oh, there she is.
Alright, there's left side Doki.
Alright, left is... I snapped her out of existence.
Do not fear.
I am someone that you can trust.
My name is Xun You.
Please spare me a moment of your time to make things clear.
There is something that I must discuss with you.
Also, like, I realized that maybe we would progress more in this game if I stopped, like, making new admires.
If I wasn't trying to increase my harem, I might have finished this game earlier.
Guan Yin!
Not Doki, I'll get straight to the point.
Can you assist us in Shrew Province?
I know that path we tread is one of great...
Oh wait, no, what the fuck?
Okay, that's just... I've done that already.
I hate Not Doki.
I got something for you today.
Just holding it in your hands is sure to put the spring of victory in your step.
It's quite a precious and rare find, after all.
So do me a favor and try not to go hawking it off to the nearest shop.
At least not before I get the chance to see you wield it.
Oh, a gift!
I'm in.
You got me a gift, guys.
Zhilong, I noticed that your eyes are frequently drawn to fire.
I'm right here.
Why do you always need to send me a letter?
I'm literally sitting right beside you.
It's like those people who, like, text you when you're, like, in the same room.
I'm like, bro, I'm in the same room with you.
Why just tell me?
Why do you have to text me this?
You almost always cry out in your sleep.
Now I can only guess, but this may have something to do with a tragic event involving fire in your forgotten past.
This is what I was thinking anyway, but I can't be sure.
You know, I was watching you cooking by the fire the other day when you took a roasted sweet potato.
And you used your requisite knife hand technique to chop it into three.
And it went and gobbled it all up yourself.
I was so sure that you would share it too.
Next time you roast sweet potatoes, lease some for me as well.
Yeah, and who is supporting you through all of this?
Who is paying for the sweet potato, Yun, huh?
You have not contributed to that right in five years.
Please, I, like, I, my paycheck does not cover two people.
Okay, I have a favor to ask of you.
Lord Sun Tzu is currently living as a vassal of Yun Shu.
I hope to be by his side during these troubled times, but seems there isn't enough room at the table for a man of my size.
That's where you come in.
I want you to check in on things there for me.
My friend, you are the only one I can trust with this task.
Alright, Yun Shu versus the Sun family.
I have a favor to ask from you.
Will you come to Xiao Pei?
We need your help defending Shu province from Yun Shu's forces.
With the Sun forces on your side, they are a formidable foe.
I feel much better we have you with us.
I implore you, please come to our aid.
Welp, sorry Hong Gai.
Today is a Shu run.
Today.
So I have to join Lu Bei.
Sorry, buddy.
Um, Medi!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay, Doki.
You're a number one Chinese person to me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At least I'm number one in somebody's heart.
Alright.
Oh, it's him.
I forgot his name.
It's Axeman.
That's me!
Yeah, it's me.
Something I- yeah, something I can do for you?
Yeah?
Have you heard about my harem?
I'm like, who the fuck is that guy?
Who's he?
Oh.
Wait, he's the leader?
What do you want me to do?
Kill him?
That doesn't come for cheap.
You know that, right?
Okay.
Oh wait, he is asking me to kill him.
Don't worry.
I'll do it for at least one dollar.
And an extra person for my harem.
Hmm.
Oh.
Lu Bei.
Oh!
Okay.
Definitely Lu Bei.
He's not incompetent or anything.
Yeah.
So honorable.
Lu Bei is like the perfect politician.
He says so many things and then does nothing.
He's actually like the most- I said Lu Bei!
Oh, I have to give everybody a choice?
Oh, I have to pick- because he joins Cao Cao's army in the end.
So I just had to pick one for him.
What about Lu Bei?
Did you not like listen to what I said about Lu Bei?
He's just like, um, hmm.
Maybe not Lu Bei.
Is there any other choices?
He's like, pass.
And I say it again, I'm like, Lu Bei.
And he's like, pass.
Cheeseburger!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Another day, more time with a game where warriors try to risk you up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, it's who needs to talk to me?
Oh, Zhao Yun!
Okay, Zhao Yun and Shu Province.
Yeah, I got it.
Where is Shu Province?
This is like the hardest part.
Okay, it's here.
So Zhao Yun should be somewhere here.
There you are.
Hello, Zhao Yun.
Farewell.
I just came over here just to meet you.
Please continue to train and protect Lord Lu Bei.
Oh, okay.
Perfect, evade.
Defeat 200 foes with spear attacks.
Defeat 200 foes with charge.
Alright.
It's spear attack time.
Alright, spear.
Where's my spears?
Lance, staff, spear.
Okay, I'm here for you.
Thank fucking God.
I was gonna be like a straighter guy if I do not have a strong-ass fucking spear.
We are not completing this.
We are not fucking completing this.
Alright.
Okay, why, why, why?
Okay.
Alright.
I shall join Lu Bei's forces.
Yes.
That's fine.
I will become enemy of the two other kingdoms.
I'm okay.
I've made my choice since the beginning.
There's only one guy in Xu's army that I want to talk to.
And he, and I don't care about anything else.
Lord Kuro says thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My services don't come cheap, Doki says, as she then asks for their little bare minimum during that time period.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I just need more people in my harem.
Yuan Shu's forces have begun an assault on us here in Xiao Pei.
We can assume that his goal is to take control of Xu.
The enemy is being led by Ji Ling, one of Yuan Shu's most trusted officers.
We also learned that warriors from the ranks of the Sun will be fighting on their side.
I'm going to beat up your future wife, Lu Bei.
I heard that after Lord Sun Jian's death, his son, Lord Sun Tse, came under the command of Yuan Shu.
It seems the rumors were true.
The enemy is formidable.
As the defenders of Xu, it is our duty to overcome this threat.
Look, if she's in the war, she's no longer a child.
I'm as eager to jump into battle as anyone, but it's all pointless if we lose you, brother.
After all, you're the only one that can protect Xu now.
Really?
The only one?
Out of everybody here, you're the only one left?
You never stop worrying about me, do you?
I'll be fine, Zhang Fei.
As long as I'll have all of you by my side, I know I'll come out of this alive.
Now, the enemy offensive is split into three parts.
We will deploy our forces to counter theirs in the same way.
One unified strength should be enough to resist Ji Ling's assault.
We should be wary of those from the Sun clan.
Sun Tse especially has lived up to his family's name as a warrior.
Yes, but our forces boast the likes of Guan Yun and Zhang Fei.
And we also have not Doki on our side.
That's me!
We will win and we will defend Xu.
This is for Lord Tao Tien and all the people of Xu who count on us for protection.
Alright, where is his future wife?
Alright, we're going down there.
Okay, that's good.
I'm positioned right there to just beat her up.
Alright, let's go.
Okay, we need Guan Yun.
Zhang Fei, I'm sorry.
You're never gonna be on my team.
Why the fuck would I choose a drunk over, like, the literal god of war?
Alright, I'm coming over.
Okay, I still remember how to play this game, I think.
I think I still remember how to play this game.
Alright, that's fine.
Then, just Y, Y, Y, Y, Y, Y, Y.
Alright, there we go.
Alright, there's still one more.
Y, Y, Y.
Okay, I missed.
Alright, the hardest combo in this game.
Y, Y, oh, whoops.
Okay, maybe I should actually get serious.
Okay, nice.
Get outta here!
You're not part of the Sun family!
You're the Yuan clan, bro!
You don't matter in history.
Where am I?
Wait, I'm up top?
Wait a minute, I thought I was supposed to be at the bottom.
Oh, it's cause I wasn't with Zhang Fei!
Alright, get over here.
Eco rights and eco lefts did not do these stories.
I'm heading over.
Sorry, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I'm heading straight for her.
You can hold out a little.
Look, I'm sorry, I have a more important mission here.
Get over here, lady!
I'm gonna teach you a lesson!
This is what you get for going into war!
Alright, don't worry, I'm over here.
Oh shit, okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, okay.
Okay, where are they feeding her?
Okay, give me a sec.
If I'm gonna...
Give me a sec, let me use an actual weapon again.
Alright, I'm gonna kill you with your own weapon.
Get outta here.
Oh, you're gonna fucking run?!
Get over here!
Get your ass over here, you're gonna fucking run?!
Oh my god, you bitch!
Why is she running?!
What the fuck?!
She literally ran away!
Okay, that's messed up.
I literally... I literally went over here just to kill her.
I can't believe it.
Alright.
I'll take this base and then I'll head over.
I'll head back.
I literally left my entire army to die just to kill this child.
In game, in game.
Just, I don't want to be clipped out of context.
Oh my god, Lupe might actually die because I went to try and beat up a child.
Oh no, okay, give me a sec.
I'm heading back, I'm heading back.
Oh, that's awkward.
Lupe, I'm sorry, I had my priorities, okay?
I had my priorities.
I was trying to teach this child to stop going into war.
Oh look, your forces are routed.
Alright, look, it's fine, it's fine.
I am a hero.
Okay, now I can swap my weapon.
Where's my spear weapon?
There you go.
Wait, oh my god, an accident.
Okay, where is it again?
I accidentally...
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Okay, why?
Why?
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, please, I'm trying to do like the fucking...
You know what?
I don't need to.
I don't... Fuck this, I don't need to complete this mission.
I'll pay to win.
It's too much.
Ow.
Oh my god, please.
Guys, it's been so long since I've played this game.
I'm like... I'm really rusty right now.
Okay, we're getting serious.
It's fine.
Guardian, please.
I need help.
Alright, this is a little awkward.
I might have to use my special attack.
Alright, get over here.
It's been so long.
Look.
Look, it's been so long, guys.
It's been so long since I've been in war.
I need to brush it all up.
Alright, nice.
Come on.
Start dancing.
When do I start dancing?
Okay, I finished one guy.
Alright.
Alright, one of them's down.
Alright, now I dance.
I breakdance.
Let's go.
Breakdance in the battlefield.
Easy.
Oh wait, I'm full HP.
Nice.
There's more?
Please, I'm like fighting six of them.
Please.
John Fei, you can fight one.
I'm fighting six.
Can you not handle one guy, John Fei?
That's all I ask for.
Oh, I do not have enough allies.
I lost all my dragoons in the war against China.
Don't say that!
I killed five!
I literally just killed five!
Okay, nice.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
Alright.
Alright, nevermind.
There's still one more.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I need to get him off his goddamn horse.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, nevermind.
Go do your arrows right here, dragoons.
In the middle of everybody.
Don't worry, you're gonna be so safe.
You'll be so safe.
Oh my god.
Please.
There's so many people around me.
Nice.
Get out of here!
Okay, nice counter.
And then...
Boom!
John Fei, did you see that?
Why can't you do that?
I can't!
John Fei, why the heck can't you do that?
I don't understand!
Alright.
Easy.
It's that easy!
There we go.
Yeah, John Fei.
Let's begin our advance.
Alright, I need to grab this base first so I can grab some buns.
I have, like, not a lot of buns left.
Hello!
I'm here to get back my house.
Thanks for, like, holding it in for a little bit.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Why does it take so long?
Wait, there's someone here?
Oh wait, no, that's just Guan Yin.
Wait, I might be able to use my staff here.
Since it's just regular guys.
Alright.
Because it's just regular people, you get the staff treatment.
That's right.
You guys are so lucky.
I'm only using you for... to rizz up some generals.
Your purpose is to die so I can rizz up Zhao Yun.
That's your entire purpose.
Alright, where are the buns?
There's the buns.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
They live... they live so I can rizz.
That's their purpose.
Alright, we gotta go downstairs here and then swap my equipment back.
I... oh my god.
Okay, let me... is there, like, an easier... I wish there was a favorite menu so I can just... I can just swap back, like, back and forth easily.
Get out of here, banner guys.
Get out of here.
You're not holding no banner.
Alright.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can we get a happy birthday for Anthony since it's his birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, I fucking... sorry, give me a sec.
I just ran past the people.
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Anthony.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Okay, let me kill this guy real quick.
Where are all their children?
I literally came over here to kill the kids.
To end their bloodline.
Alright, let's go over here.
Let's get rid of this guy too.
How are you gonna lose?
Oh my god.
Okay, you gotta get out.
You gotta stop drinking, buddy.
Alright, I'm coming over.
The moment I kill this one old man.
Alright.
Don't worry, John Fae.
I'm coming over.
Oh buddy, we might need intervention.
You gotta stop drinking, man.
I swear to god, if you're struggling against a child...
Alright, you're so... okay, yeah, you are.
You're...
Alright, child.
I'm ready to fight you.
That's right.
Guys, you wanna watch me fight a child?
Get over here.
Oh my god.
Okay, you gotta go home.
You can't what?
Little girl!
That's right, go home!
It's bedtime.
Maybe you gotta go home, little girl.
I can't believe we just saw her beat up a child.
That's right, you wanna see me do it again?
Permanent bedtime.
Alright, let's get rid of him too.
No, I'm okay.
Don't worry.
Arrow time.
Alright, stand in front of all these swordsman dragoons.
You'll be fine.
Trust me.
Alright, he's almost dead.
I'm not gonna use my Yusou for this, man.
He's just one guy.
He doesn't even have like a unique model, but he's still part of the Sun family somehow.
Alright, nice.
And then...
My base now.
Alright, let me grab the top two just in case.
Alright, nice!
Okay, let's go this way.
Oh nice, I can be Guan Yu finally.
The real game starts soon.
Alright, let's kill this guy because apparently my team is struggling somehow against this one guy.
Alright.
Get out of here.
You don't have a name.
Your name is literally someone else's name.
Alright, let's hope that Zhang Fei doesn't die.
Let's hope that the five seconds I left there and Zhang Fei will be okay.
Alright, Zhang Fei, I'm coming over.
You just killed a child.
Amazing work.
This is why you're the boss.
Alright.
You know what?
You know what time it is?
It's Guan Yu time.
Alright, so you're gonna protect your father's legacy?
That's funny.
Have you ever fought the god of war before?
Yeah?
You think your father's gonna be happy?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna humble you real quick.
Oh man, you're gonna use your special move?
That's right.
There we go.
Oh man.
That's so funny.
Oh, are you ever gonna choose one move?
Oh man.
What is he doing?
Is he meditating?
What are you doing?
What is he doing?
What is he- Is he just meditating?
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, I'll finish the job.
Easy.
Bro, he was like meditating in the middle of the fight.
There's a time and place, man.
Wait, is this where Lu Bei is fighting?
Lu Bei, what the fuck are you doing here?
Lu Bei, get out of here!
You're the general!
You were not meant to do this!
Oh, okay.
A duel?
Oh, you saw how I beat up your sister?
I can do it again.
You want to see me do it again?
Same thing I did to her.
Oh man.
You tried, Sun Quan.
You really did try.
But I guess I'm gonna end your father's bloodline.
Oh, goodbye.
This was faster than the child.
Nice.
That was unfortunately faster than killing the child.
I think I know who has not been in war.
Alright, nice.
True warrior!
I am a true warrior now.
Alright, let's see.
Get him out of here.
Alright, nice.
I gotta get to him too.
You may as well.
They're just XP farm for me.
Alright.
Oh, one more hit.
One more hit.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
Okay, not yeah.
Not yeah.
Yeah!
My base.
True warrior.
True warrior by beating up a child.
Nice.
All I'm saying is that Sun Quan should really stop sending children to war.
Alright.
Is he dueling me?
No?
Coward.
I'm gonna start breakdancing now.
You should have accepted my duel.
I feel like I should be allowed to challenge people to duels.
Like why?
How come they get to challenge me and I can't challenge them?
Alright, get out of here.
Oh man.
Sorry, Ji Ling.
Don't worry.
I'm almost done with them.
And then you can go home.
Go home!
Yay!
Goodbye.
Wait, is he even gonna fight back?
He literally hired a...
He literally hired a hydrogen bomb to fight these babies.
Like none of them have ever fought back before.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna beat you up in the corner.
Goodbye.
Yay!
Fight back, I say as I pummel him into the ground.
Why aren't you fighting back?
We did it!
Yay!
Alright.
Nice.
I hope she's getting stronger.
Alright, 15 skill point.
I won one duel.
Nice.
As if that was a challenge.
And then... Oh, nice.
I can...
Equip more accessories now.
Absol, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When you ask someone to make a choice for you and they pick the option you secretly didn't want.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ah, yeah.
Sickness and not like poison or anything.
That was infamous during the Dynasty Warriors era.
You're all here.
Brother, what did you talk about with Lord Tao Ch'in?
The future?
It appears that his lordship very much wants me to go to the Domainship of Shu.
You already refused the appointment.
Yes, I did.
I didn't believe I was up to the task.
And my opinion on that has not changed.
But...
How do you grow a beard?
When you start to own land, you grow a beard.
It's the way of the law.
It's like when you become a dad, you just start wearing socks with sandals.
You should accept, please.
I'm tired of being homeless.
I'm tired of you living in my apartment, please.
Get your own place.
Please, you need your own place.
I'm tired of you mooching off of my apartment.
Move out now.
It's fine if it's just you, but then you bring your two brothers.
We have one bed.
Yeah, doesn't he have sons?
Passed on and Lu Bei became the governor of Shu...
Like, what about his sons?
Like, what about Tao Qian's sons?
Imagine being like the son of the governor and then the guy was like, sorry.
This random dude that you don't know is gonna take over the province now.
Sorry, buddy.
They don't matter.
Alright, let's go to Inn.
Let's see if we have any new letters.
Oh, we have a lot.
Alright, what is upgraded now?
Expands attack range, boosts damage dealt to enemies with parries.
Ooh, wait, that's really good.
Alright, do I have any fan mail?
Did you know that when your guard is supposedly down, you're as silent as a shadow?
I noticed this about you not long after we started living together.
When you go about your daily life, you make plenty of noise just like the rest of us.
But when you wake up, leave the terrible or return for the night, generally when you stop focusing on the world around you, your movements suddenly go silent.
Most people are just the opposite.
I wonder if you had some kind of training in the past that gave you this ability.
Ooh, I'm mysterious.
That's what makes him so drawn to me.
If that was the case, it must have been a long and thorough process for it to be innate to the point of it practically being a bodily function.
The kinds of people who do that sort of training are... no.
You must not let your imagination wander too far.
What I do know for certain is that you actually make noise on purpose to avoid startling me when you draw near.
Although you do leave the room quite messy from time to time.
The little acts of courtesy like that are what makes you unique.
Oh, what?
Oh, I'm sorry for being a terrible roommate.
At least I pay rent.
What have you done?
Since you're living for free here, you might as well, you know, help me clean.
You know?
Not be a fucking freeloader.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, hey, JonFay wants to talk.
What did I talk about?
Doki, he's your live-in doctor, not your live-in maid.
Look, he's barely being a doctor right now.
I'm just saying.
I feel like we should split up the chores that matches the contribution to the household.
He's going to want to give him a hand.
Even though men like Louie Boo are nothing but trouble.
Why don't you stop?
Why not just help him?
Yeah, why not just help him?
I'm not totally against the idea.
After all, our brother never fails to provide aid to those who ask.
All I'm saying is that...
But it's Louie Boo we're talking about here.
I mean, he treats me alright.
He invited me to dinner, guys.
A private dinner with me and Louie Boo.
I think he seems like an alright man.
Even though he did murder thousands of men.
He seems like an alright guy because he treated me to dinner.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, rescue of Louie Boo.
Okay, we gotta rescue Louie Boo.
Okay, before we do that, we gotta search for the moon grass.
Where the fuck is the moon grass?
Always show map.
Okay.
Oh, it's in Jin province.
Alright, let's go to Jin province real quick.
And find this...
This grass for my fucking drug.
Uh...
Lian province, Jin province.
Alright, it should be here.
Okay,
it's not here.
How the fuck?
Where is this?
Am I still in Jin?
Where am I anymore?
No, I'm still in Jin.
Okay.
Where is this?
Where is it?
Is it back here?
Okay, they locked it.
Uh...
Am I in Jin yet still?
I'm still in Jin, right?
Yeah, I am.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, I'm so...
Okay, no.
That's not Jin.
Okay, this here is Jin.
Alright.
Am I still there?
Alright, I'm like at the edge of Jin.
So like, the doors have yet to open.
Unless it's over here.
Alright, this is still Jin.
Freedom!
Where the fuck is this stupid moongrass?
Is this moongrass?
No, that's just a coin.
Alright, so...
No incense for me.
God damn it.
I cannot find this moongrass.
Oh, it's located... Oh yeah, you're right.
It's located in the moon.
I'm still there.
I'm still in Jin province.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I think I found it.
Is this moongrass?
Oh, there it is.
I found moongrass.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Alright, my child doctor.
Drug me up.
Make me see those funky visions.
Okay, not here.
Sorry, I forgot.
I had to go home for that.
Alright.
Alright, my child doctor.
I had to go all the way back here.
Or was it here?
I don't remember.
What funky visions?
Don't worry.
Don't worry about it.
My doctor prescribed it to me, so it's safe.
What?
Oh, there he is.
He might be like underage, but I trust him.
Oh, that herb?
You've done well to bring me such a specimen.
That's something else.
Seems you have a keen eye for plants.
Impressive.
I need to make an incense out of this right away.
Let's head over to the village.
Being there might help you remember.
Alright, here we go.
It's time to light it up.
With my child doctor.
Is your doctor qualified?
All the other doctors are dead.
So all I have is a child.
That's what trauma does to you.
Oh, we're sheltered!
Oh my god, that's the easiest type of village to take over.
When they don't know the outside world.
That means they're not exposed to like the outside bacteria yet.
We can give them the plague.
We can give them chickenpox.
I can't help hoping that they won't grow up like us.
Is that arrogant of me?
Do you think?
I want us to be the end of it.
The last guardians of peace.
I dream of a day when the realm doesn't...
I hope they can accomplish what they're trying to do.
You know, bring peace to the world back then.
I wonder if it worked and we never had wars after that.
Or like any type of world war.
Cause they're the last guardians of peace.
Guys, do you think they did it?
Do you think it worked?
They finally got rid of all wars.
War went extinct forever.
Alright, let's see.
Let me check real quick.
Did they accomplish their goal?
Well,
he was a brutal dictator or a feudal China when I was dating him.
Exactly.
He was nice to me though.
Alright.
Do I have any... Oh, I don't?
Oh, it's cause of the other...
Oh, I lost the interaction with the other guy because I was like...
I was like, shoo forever baby.
I don't understand those types of friends.
I know like...
You know how there's people who are like...
Obviously they're friends with people who are pieces of shit.
But then they'll be like Yeah, but he wasn't a piece of shit to me though.
And they'll still hang out with him.
As long as he wasn't an asshole to me, it's okay.
He commits a couple of war crimes.
Real.
Too real.
No, but you don't get it though.
Doki, you don't get it.
Let's see, where's my spear?
Alright, there you go.
Support the homies no matter what type of war crimes they do.
Is that it?
Alright, let's get him out of here.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Goodbye!
He's sitting too close to home.
Are you supporting a war criminal, Orange?
What do you mean?
He's sitting too close to home.
Okay.
Oh wait, this guy is strong.
So is I.
That's bad.
Alright.
Alright, nice.
Let me get rid of him real quick.
Pros before international law.
Alright, but my war crimes are in-game.
It's okay.
I'm making sure I'm getting rid of my urges in-game so it never becomes reality.
So that's different, guys.
Criminals just need to let out their steam in virtual reality and then everything will be fine.
When we put all the criminals in virtual reality, the world will be a more peaceful place.
Oh my god, it's so perfect.
Do not allow the peasants to be defeated.
I'm trying my best!
Alright, let's go.
Yay, I did it.
I saved the peasants.
So Australia, why don't we just like deport all the criminals to like a random secluded island and then... Like all I'm saying is we did that once before and Australia came out just fine.
All I'm saying is like, they are maybe a little like, you know, a little rowdy but Australia came out fine.
We can make Australia 2.0!
Oh my god, I have to head all the way over there.
Oh, it's because they have two people beating him up.
Whoops, I should have chose the other side first.
I'm trying my best.
My horse is not that fast, man.
Is he okay?
Please, eat some bread.
Eat some bread.
Please, there's a lot.
Please, I'm getting fucking body blocked by 200 people.
Like...
Alright.
Honestly?
No, no.
New Zealand?
No, no, no.
I don't trust New Zealand.
I can't remember like how...
Okay, when COVID was a thing?
Okay, it still is.
It was.
Sorry.
When COVID was a worse thing and then like somehow New Zealand was like one of the only countries that had like barely any cases of COVID.
Cases of COVID?
What did they do?
It's all a conspiracy.
It's all like a fee thing with New Zealand.
But it's actually crazy that like New Zealand was able to do what no other country could.
Dude, have you been to New Zealand?
That New Zealand conspiracy.
They also really like sheep.
Be a remote...
Yeah, but Australia is a remote island.
They have more sheep than people.
Dude, they're an island.
I'm just joking guys.
I do think it's very impressive that they were able to like fix COVID.
When like the rest of the world was like in shambles.
They were actually able to be like we're okay.
Yeah.
That's why all I'm saying is that New Zealand New Zealand has some space.
I mean, Australia came out okay.
Australia came out okay when we, you know, put all our criminals there.
We could do it again.
New Zealand, the home of Lord of the Rings.
The home of the shy.
Alright, let's see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I know she commits war crimes but you haven't heard her crow.
We have guards now?
The guards will continue to defend the spot until they receive an order to return.
What if I just send the guards all the way Imagine if I just send the guard to like end game.
Just try to kill the leader.
You're all two of you by yourself.
You'll be fine, don't worry.
Wait, I shouldn't even mean...
What are my gems?
Attack range...
Yeah, we'll do the attack range.
Okay,
let's get this one real quick.
What is this, level 30?
I'm level 31.
Let's get two more guards in here.
Rest in peace, those two dragons.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Last I heard, there was this war to end all wars.
I wonder how that went.
Yeah, that was the last one too, right?
Right?
That was the last one.
Boom.
Boom, get out of here.
Alright, nice.
Alright, that was easy.
Pretty sure.
Yeah, so the guard, they did it!
The guardians of peace did it!
Yay!
Okay.
Just fuck that one guy in particular.
Alright.
Alright, let's see here.
Boop.
Get out of here.
Alright.
Come on.
Why do you have so much HP?!
All you're gonna do is die anyway!
That's right!
Get in the corner!
Get in the naughty corner!
It's your time out, buddy!
Okay.
You're just XP for my Riz!
You don't matter!
I'm literally using you to level up my Riz!
Get cornered!
Damn!
That's fucking right!
That's your entire purpose!
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's see how much more I need.
God, the perfect evade is gonna be fucking a struggle.
Uh, 123...
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, let me...
Oh, wait, fuck.
Okay.
I forgot how to dodge, so this is gonna be interesting.
I always forget to dodge.
Boom!
Nice.
Oh my god, they're just gone.
Alright, one more.
Two more, actually.
Oh my god, this one guy is very confident.
Woo!
Alright.
C'mon.
Get outta here.
Get outta here!
Get your ass outta here!
This is your only purpose!
I'm literally only doing this mission so I can finish my Dao Yun Riz.
Nice.
Get outta here!
That's fucking right!
Life doesn't matter!
Your entire purpose is so I can Riz feudal Chinese generals!
Hahaha!
Alright.
Get out.
Hello, this is a 1v1.
Leave.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Nice.
We have 7 out of 13 guards.
What happened to my other guards?
How did you guys die?
Okay.
And then...
Boop.
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
Sorry, I'm just beating up this one guy in the corner.
Like, it's not even a challenge.
It's literally like my to-do list for the day.
It's a chore, unfortunately.
That's how little his life matters.
Hahaha!
Boop!
Nice!
Fight back!
It's like...
It's like my morning routine.
8am, I kill this general.
8.02, I kill this other general.
8.03.
Hahaha!
Alright, nice.
Plus 6.
I did that.
Alright, now to...
Strengthen allied troops.
What, my own?
Oh, I can learn a new tactic.
Okay, how do I...
equip it, though?
Oh wait, I have another accessory!
Okay.
Wait, what am I using?
Okay, 5% health when an officer is defeated.
Okay.
Boost health by 20%?
I feel like I always need health.
Increases damage taken...
Uh, defense...
Restore health...
Boost attack...
Boost, wait...
For each allied base you have...
When you stop...
Restore is 10%.
Reduce attack...
I feel like I always need health, though.
Boost defense strength.
Boost attack strength.
Okay, I'm gonna get the health.
Uh... Alright, squad.
Oh, there we go.
Encouragement, charge...
Order...
The guards will continue to defend this spot until they receive an order.
Okay, we'll do...
How much encouragement do I get?
And then, charge.
We'll do charge and... charge and encouragement.
Oh!
I got an offering!
Also got yoink.
Sash, boost attack speed.
Oh, nice.
Thank you for the free offering, guys.
Abso!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They were too afraid...
Of spreading it to their beloved sheep, so they...
So they were being extra cautious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not the sheep.
Was pursued by Cao Cao and Yuan Shao.
Yuan Shao is still involved?
Bro!
After you have the yellow turbans, you don't matter.
Your existence is like...
Obsolete.
That's why you're yellow.
That was your only purpose in this story.
Alright.
We have received a call for aid from Lord Lu Bu and I plan to answer it.
Lord Lu Bu and his men are on the run.
Pursued by Yuan Shao.
We need to protect them until they can reach somewhere safe.
Defeating Yuan Shao will end the chase, but having to cut through his massive forces to get him to make it nigh is impossible.
You know what?
I can do it.
Oh my god, wait.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna take my horse and go straight in there.
Hardest so when both I and Lord Lu Bu must survive, Lu Bu will be fine.
We will rendezvous with Lu Bu and then fend off the enemy while making our retreat.
I can do it, guys!
Lu Bu does not need rescuing.
I'm gonna take my horse and go straight in.
What's the worst that could happen?
Guys, what possibly could be the worst thing that could happen to me?
It might be the worst thing that could happen to Lu Bei or Lu Bu, but not me.
Absolutely.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That time I died and reincarnated in ancient China and rinsed up all the war heroes.
The new hit Isekai anime in 2025.
I know that y'all have mixed feelings about him, but he has made himself no shortage of enemies.
But when he asked for my help, I felt compelled to give it.
Yeah, I thought that might be the case.
Well, if that's your decision, brother, we are with you all the way.
We will go where you lead us, brother.
Gator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gonna take her horse down the old...
Gonna take my horse down the old Silk Road.
So, I've never liked that Lu Bu.
I'd rather take his life than save it.
Nonetheless, thank you both.
Not Doki, will you come with us too?
Yes, but I'll fight my way.
Exactly.
I will fight through this.
This concludes the War Council.
Let's head out when everyone is ready.
Stop giving me John Fei.
You're not gonna make me take John Fei over Guan Yu.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm going straight in.
Lu Bu, you'll live, right?
Bro, it's not even that far.
It'll be fine.
It's such a short journey.
I should change my equipment though.
If I'm gonna do this.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm almost there.
I'm coming in.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I swear to god.
It will work, guys.
Guys, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna...
Don't worry.
It's gonna work, guys.
I might be like...
Okay.
Guys, I think...
I think, guys...
Don't worry.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
I feel so healthy right now.
I feel incredibly healthy right now.
It's fine.
It's fine, guys.
It's...
Okay.
Guys, I feel so healthy.
I have no more buns.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I may or may not have no more buns, but it's okay.
I can do this.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm safe.
I'm okay.
I feel so...
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
It's okay.
I have this.
I look very safe.
It's okay.
I feel so safe, guys.
I feel incredibly safe.
It's okay.
See?
Look at that.
We're so healthy.
Oh, look at that.
Wait.
What do you mean?
See?
Look at that.
We're so healthy.
I told you.
I told you, guys.
No, no, no.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
I told you.
See?
Look at that.
We're fine.
We got extra buns, too.
Okay, but where is he?
Oh, he's over there.
Okay.
I told you.
Wait, what?
Wait, why are they mobilizing?
It's literally just me.
Why are they mobilizing?
Please.
Why are you mobilizing?
It's literally just me.
Like, stop.
Stop.
Okay.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm almost there.
Where is he?
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
Challenge me, please.
Challenge me to a duel.
Please.
If you challenge me to a duel, this can all be over.
Just let me challenge you to a duel, please.
Please, I...
Please.
If you challenge me to a duel, this can be over.
Okay.
Alright, guys, this might be...
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I only have one more button, guys.
Guys, I...
Guys, I'm not okay right now.
I'm not okay.
Just 1v1 me, bro.
Just 1v1 me.
That's all I ask for.
It's just this.
Come on.
1v1 me, bro.
1v1 me.
Come on.
Just 1v1 me, bro.
Guys, I don't have any more buttons.
I don't have any more buttons, guys.
This is a little bad.
I don't...
Are you serious?
How do we have more?
Okay.
Okay, we gotta kill him.
No!
Okay.
Guys, all I'm saying was that it was an incredibly good effort.
I literally...
Everyone might have been dead, but like, I killed more...
I killed two-thirds of his army.
I did kill two-thirds of his army by myself.
I literally soloed his army, guys.
Like, I died, but like, it was a good effort.
It was a good try.
I just had like...
All I'm saying is that if I had just a little bit more buttons, we could have made it work.
It would have been possible.
It was just...
It was just a shortage of buttons.
I surprisingly lived a lot longer than I expected.
Look, that is why I'm not a strategist here.
I thought I could take him!
It's fine.
Look at that.
There we go.
Now, I trained so much for this that like, this is nothing to me.
If only it was just him.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you, guys.
It's time to eat your buns.
Okay.
Look at that.
It's like...
I'm so...
After defeating an entire fucking army, this is like nothing to me.
Like, who would have thought?
Alright.
Nice.
Encourage my allies!
Let's go!
Alright, nice.
There's so many things happening, but I killed them so fast that they can't even talk.
That's me!
Wait, where is he?
Oh, there he is!
Don't worry, Lu Bu.
Also, where the fuck was Lu Bu during my entire 1v1 entire army?
There we go.
I did it.
Alright.
Lay me on the buns.
All I'm saying is that if I had enough buns, everything would have been fine.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You're brave.
I'll give you that.
I could have done it.
I could have taken him.
If I had one more bun, I could have done it.
That coward!
It's just because that coward wouldn't 1v1 me.
If your chat 1v1 me, it would have been over.
Nice.
Goodbye.
No dancing for you.
Oh, nice.
What did I get?
A crescent blade charged strong attack can be powered up by relentlessly chain- Oh, wait!
Is that Guan Yu's blade?
Wait, I got his blade!
Nice.
Alright.
Got his blade.
Now I can be the god of war.
Get out of here.
Alright, guys.
I can take him.
Guys, I think now...
Guys, I think I can...
I think I can...
Now that I got Guan Yu's blade, I think I can take him.
Second time...
Second time's the charm, okay?
Oh, I'm saved.
No, no, no, no.
Guys, guys, guys.
This time...
I can do it.
This time.
I swear.
I can...
Alright, let's get him out of here.
Fine.
I guess like, if we wanna be little bitches, I guess I won't.
But I think I can kill Cao Cao.
You know what?
I can kill Cao Cao.
I trust you.
I believe.
Guys, I can do it.
I just need more buns.
But like, I think I can take Cao Cao.
Alright, I'm going in.
Get out of here.
I'm going straight in.
I'm going.
I can do it.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
I think...
I think I can do it.
Round 2.
You'll never learn.
No, this is different.
This is different.
This is so different, guys.
This is Cao Cao.
This is so different.
Where's my HP?
Where did my HP go?
Where is my HP?
I can still do it.
I can still do it, guys.
I don't know what happened to my HP.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
It's fine.
HP disappeared.
Can't shatter my confidence if I'm too dumb to realize it.
There we go.
That's all I'm saying.
You can't shatter shit if I don't know what's going on.
There we go.
I told you guys.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
I told you.
I told you I can take him.
I fucking told you.
I told you I can do it.
I can take him down.
No one believe me.
No.
I can't believe it.
Look at that.
I told you.
Wait.
How did he retake that base?
I can't believe no one buddy believed that.
There you go.
I told you.
You know what?
I feel so confident now.
I feel so fucking confident now.
I'm going for it.
You know what?
I can take him.
He's overconfident.
You know what?
I can take him.
Get over here.
I told you I just needed more buns.
Alright, get over here.
Where is he?
I don't even see my arrows.
I feel so confident.
I don't know where he is but I feel so confident.
Where the fuck is he?
Alright, there's like so many names in front of me so I need to find him.
Okay.
Alright.
I don't know where he is guys.
Like, that's the issue.
I literally can't see anything.
Alright.
There we go.
True warrior time.
Where's Yuan Shao?
Where is he?
I don't see Yuan Shao anywhere in here.
There's so many names.
Where is Yuan Shao's name?
Which one is it?
I see just too many names.
Where is he?
No!
He walked Bro, he just walked past me.
My kill!
Bro, he just walked away?
I can't believe it!
We could've taken him!
Not a real victory.
I can't believe it.
What's the point?
I could've taken him guys!
I could've taken him!
JohnnyLacon, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Even if Doki survives this, the great bow shortage will lead to the starvation of many peasants in the coming months.
Is this truly the cost of bromance?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cowards.
I can't believe it.
The great Lu Bu running away like that.
Goddamn cowards!
We could've done it!
Jansky, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lu Bu, a special dialogue.
Can you beat both Yuan Shao and Cao Cao by the way?
I was going to!
I could've done it!
Ooh, that's true.
He couldn't defeat an entire army like me.
And they wrote stories about him?
What about me?
I literally took on two entire armies!
And I almost won.
You'll have to forgive those who would err that way.
I might have won, but I almost did.
Look, if I look less generic, people will remember me too.
That's true, a thousand people that died to like save this one guy.
Hello, I'm here?
Hello?
In front of me?
Did I not just beat up Cao Cao's army by myself?
Like, hello?
In front of me?
Like, I don't know.
Am I not like, am I invisible?
He wrote me off of this.
I literally just came back from that fight too.
Oh, oh.
Oh, for doubt, guys.
It was not the right decision, guys.
Oh, Lupe.
Oh, hey.
Yeah, from the date we had?
Like, what do you mean?
Did he forgot?
What?
You invited me?
What do you mean?
I remember who you are.
What do you mean she?
What do you mean?
What?
We had dinner together.
Oh my God, my heart.
After everything we forgot already.
I spent so much money on you.
I thought we had a special...
You're still thinking about Diao Chan?
I sold my weapons just to be with you.
Why would she be with me?
Yeah, but like...
But like...
It could be like a sad thing.
I can't believe it.
I sold my weapons for him to afford our dates.
It was like a host club situation where I used up all my income to talk to him.
Oh my God, he host clubbed me.
Oh my God, who put the incense in my room again?
Nonetheless, these ideals mark him as a man capable of rising above all others.
If they become reality, the snake that crawls the earth will take flight and rule the sky as a dragon.
Guardian of peace.
Dude, start speaking in real.
If you believe that Liu Bei is the hero that will bring an end to the chaos, then walk alongside him.
Alice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just need more buns.
Chatoki 2025.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I went to debt for Lu Bu.
And then he's like, Hey you, I remember you.
You're with the chat.
I was with you!
Remember Moongrass?
It's one of the aromics I had you bring to me for your treatment.
I neglected to mention it before, but its scent is also known for its ability to focus the mind.
You spend a lot of time refining pyroxen into gems, and I think it might just be the thing to help you in your work.
If you come across any Moongrass on your travels, I highly recommend taking it with you.
Okay, now harvest Moongrass.
Whoops.
I forgot.
My zero is buying to it.
Jarhons, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We could have been dating.
I mean taking him.
No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Lupe.
Our shared dream.
I want to talk to you.
Just the two of us.
Lupe's my rebound.
After my heart was broken, he is my rebound.
I hope that you will not dread my visit as yet another problem to solve.
I also need to keep this from Guan Yun and Zhang Fei.
There is something I need to tell you and you alone.
I look forward to seeing you.
And his brothers don't even know.
Alright, where is he?
Jonathan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lupe, who is this in there?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There is something I need to talk with you about.
Alright.
I would go to Guan Yun and Zhang Fei with this, but let's just say it's a delicate subject with those two.
Is it confession time?
Of course, I don't mind.
Thanks.
You're a great help.
I wanted to discuss Lord Li Bu.
You've just welcomed him to Shu.
We're talking about Lu Bu?
Bro, what about me?
What about my name?
What do you mean?
I need to bring him up!
I can't believe we're still talking about Lu Bu after all this time.
We're still talking about him.
Even when he's not here, we still talk about him.
Oh!
It's just me?
Oh my god!
I have a tighter bond than sworn brothers?
Oh!
Yeah!
Your life is yours to live in whatever way you wish.
Beyond this point, you must discern which heroes are capable of achieving peace so that you can choose a faction to join.
Your action may also draw you to a single faction.
Heed their call and continue your journey.
If you're aligned with multiple factions, you will be forced to choose between the two.
Reflect on your experiences and think carefully when making the choice.
I'll join you.
Don't worry.
I'll join you, my rebound.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You went into debt with the mafia for him.
I know it!
Then he forgot about me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice.
Finally, we did it.
We finally, after eight streams, we finally joined a fucking faction.
I've joined Lu Bu.
I just felt all the tension leave my body.
I am so deeply relieved.
What am I saying?
I'm already embarrassing myself again, aren't I?
You were very special to me.
I hope we can make the most of the time we have together.
How special, Lu Bu.
My rebound.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I lost everything because of you.
I don't even know who you are.
My heart.
How many chapters is there anyway?
He made great efforts to establish a new regime centered on Shu.
In the face of this, Yuan Shao and the other powerful clans could not remain docile, and their ambitions were soon laid bare.
Elsewhere, Sun Ce worked with Zhou Yu on a plan... Oh, Zhou Yu came back?
His roommate came back, guys.
Possibilities seemed to stretch out all the way to the horizon.
Although Liu Bei had now allied with the peerless warrior Lu Bu, he fell into doubt.
Unable to decide on the path he should take.
With the entire land facing great uncertainty, it's his responsibility to capture the city.
Cao Cao rises up to the job.
Liu Bei faces a quandary in Xiapei.
Cao Cao fights a decisive battle at Guandu.
Jade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you read The Ravages of Time manga?
I highly recommend it.
It's the whole stage of the Three Kingdoms of a totally different saga of the Three Kingdoms.
A totally different take.
No, I haven't.
I might look at... check it out after the stream.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm green now!
Oh.
I'm gonna blend right in.
On the grass.
Camouflage.
This is barely green.
Wait, I'm not even green.
I have no regrets.
I'm making decisions after being broken up with by Liu Bei.
Clearly, my mind is sound.
It's not even green.
What outfit did I change into?
Wait,
he's red.
Why did we let her red here?
This is green territory.
What?
Oh.
Oh, Cao Cao's puppeteering right now.
Yes, the most trustworthy of the two.
I want Liu Bei to grow a mustache!
You own land now!
Just don't shave!
Why do you talk like this if you want me to be convinced that you're not sus?
Oh man, I will never betray you.
You can trust me.
Of course!
I am the most innocent out of the two.
Just talk normally if you want me not sus.
Yes, stay here.
You almost died like six times from one guy.
I don't trust you.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Reminder that Liu Bei slept in the same bed as Guan Yun and Zhang Fei.
But you're the one who can open up!
We're both rebounding, okay?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Yes.
Look, keeping watch is important, Zhang Fei.
As long as we don't put him near any alcohol, it should be fine, right?
More booze at home!
Yippee!
His entire purpose, god!
I mean, there's still one other option.
You know?
He didn't say anything.
He's like, thanks for cheering me up.
Dot, dot, dot, dot.
Me.
I'm helping.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
We need that.
Oh, I have a letter!
Wait, I can't fight yet.
I have to... Oh, I am so underleveled.
Oh, hey!
Everybody's here!
Hey, guys!
Would you be willing to assist me with something?
Oh, a request.
How about you?
I see you got an adventure ahead of me.
A fine test of a man's metal.
Okay.
I got another request.
Alright, let me look at my letters.
I gotta look at my fan mail real quick.
So, two hundred and... I am broke!
I do not have that money.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
It's time to sell, apparently.
Oh, my god.
What do you mean?
Two hundred and...
I spent all my money at the host club!
At the Chinese General Host Club!
Okay.
This is not fair.
I spent all my money there.
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
A hundred and fifty-two?
What weapon is this?
Why is it so strong?
The money well spent.
Wow.
Throwing silver coin.
Oh!
This is Zhugotlan.
Do you remember when we last met?
I mentioned I would invite you to my retreat.
I recently felt that it was a good time to show you how life is deep into these mountains and decide to reach out to you once more.
The road here is a bit steep, but you can make the journey.
Oh!
Let's go!
I'm going to visit the host club!
My favorite host is there!
Let's go!
Guys, my favorite host is there right now!
I need to go!
Wait, where did he... okay, here.
Do not...
Stop spending money on them!
They don't understand!
Oh my god!
Oh wait, that's not him.
That's just an old man.
He has some stuff.
Okay.
What is this?
Wait, where is he?
Chuko-Lan!
Where are you?
I'm here!
My favorite host is here!
Where is he?
Oh!
Hello!
Don't worry!
I withdrew some funds!
From my bank!
To talk to you!
Please!
No more host club!
The dragoons are sad!
I swear I saw it.
The journey was long indeed.
I'm just...
Mentally, there's a mustache in my head.
Just me?
Oh my god, he hasn't met his wife yet.
That means there's a chance.
I would change history so he never meets his wife.
I'm gonna change history.
Thank you!
You are special!
I haven't even told you what it is yet.
Still, the gift is, as you so surmised, vegetable in nature.
On a different note, I have heard you serve Lord Liu Bei as of late.
Tales of your exploits have reached even my ears.
For you, a guardian of peace, to treat yourself so wholeheartedly is in a word.
He's gonna be interested in me over his wife.
His future ex-wife.
Because there won't be a wife.
Guardian of peace, killer of millions.
Oh my god.
Browse some ideas.
I can't believe he chose Liu Bei as his master.
It's not homewrecking!
It's like they never got together.
If I change the fate, and they never meet.
Perhaps one could just as easily call it the rationalization of an arrogant man.
One neglecting to do his duty at that.
Living here, isolated from the world, makes it a common occurrence to go days without speaking to a single soul.
It would seem having you here has rendered me quite loquacious indeed.
What is more, I appreciate the restraint.
I half expected an attempt to recruit me into Lord Liu Bei's cadre of tacticians.
When the time comes for me to choose my master, I wish to try something for now unclouded by preconceived notions.
Now then, will you be setting off tomorrow?
You are welcome to stay here, modest though my retreat may be.
Remain here as long as you like, or as long as you can stomach such close quarters.
Oh my god!
Did you see the side eye?
Okay guys, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Actually, I was like, oh I need to use the bathroom.
No, this conversation is very important.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
NotSoDeadPool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Reminder, Adoki, these host club visits can't be marked as business expense.
It can't be if I'm streaming it, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It is.
I streamed it.
It's a business expense now.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
This is my medical doctor, by the way.
This is my licensed doctor that's supposed to, like, take care of me.
He is now thinking...
He is now assuming in his medical report that I am a cat.
Alright,
we don't care.
...to see potential.
The only gems created will be those you saw.
Incense only has an effect once.
If you use incense while creating any gems and then use another incense, the first effect will be overridden.
Oh, okay.
So...
Alright, okay.
What is it?
Oh, so it increases that specific gem.
You know what?
I need the range anyway.
Yeah, that's fine.
Actually, these are good.
Fine.
Alright.
I'll only get this.
Yeah, I actually wanted those specific gems anyway.
Those are the only gems I wanted.
Boarding the ship.
God!
Oh, wait.
Gems.
Okay, wait.
We have to go back home because my doctor wants to speak to me.
Again.
My doctor or... Oh, wait.
Who is he?
Wait, is that Yun-Yun?
Get out!
Leave!
He's mine!
How dare you!
Leave!
No!
I'll send her to war.
I'll send her to war!
She'll die in the battlefield before he meets her.
I'll change history.
He's mine!
Why?
I stayed at his house!
Bitch!
I'll send her to the front line.
And you are?
No!
You're supposed to be ugly!
Stop!
I came to visit here because...
well...
Destroying weapons is something of a specialty of yours, right?
This lady here enjoys inventing tools that better people's lives.
It's true!
That's the only... People are like, why did Zhuge Liang marry her?
She's so ugly.
But then he's like, yeah, but it's her inner beauty because she's supposed to be like, incredibly smart and everything.
And like, he married her for her inner beauty and mind instead of her like, looks.
So why did she make him... Why did they make her pretty?
No!
Go back home!
I don't need you here!
How dare you make lives easier for people!
Go home!
I don't wanna help her.
Wait!
If I assist you in however way I can, I can be close to her and make sure she doesn't meet Zhuge Liang.
I'll make sure you never meet him.
But not consider my goal foolish?
Yes.
Many have been suspicious of my motives or doubted that the knowledge I seek will lead to anything.
You have to meet her right after meeting Zhuge Liang.
Like, I'm so sad.
You should keep going.
Maybe it'll lead to your death.
You're right.
I have no time to question myself.
I shall encourage her.
And steer her to the battlefield.
Oh my god, if I seduce her, she won't- Then she won't fall in love with him.
Oh yes!
Fall in love with me!
This is a long game, guys.
Yes!
I am the first one!
It's supposed to be Zhuge Liang to be the first, but I took it.
Now she'll not fall in love with him.
That's good.
I can't believe Tokyo is trying to NTR her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, it's different!
This is different, guys.
Alright, okay.
Alright, I should go see her.
No, it's different.
It's a long game.
It's a long con.
I get her interested in me so that I can have him all to myself.
So her heart will no longer have room for him.
It's just that easy.
Alright.
Yeah, exactly.
It's not NTR if I take her place.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, it's in Albor Green.
Alright.
Okay, where do I have to go?
Where is Yu Yang?
Where is she?
Oh, there she is.
What territory is this?
Oh, it's in Shu.
Or, no, it's not.
Where the fuck is she?
Yeah, it's here.
Oh, I have to go here.
Okay.
Oh, there she is.
I'll make sure I see, like, any of that Albor grass or whatever.
That?
No, it's locked.
Alright.
Our talk earlier was incredibly inspiring, so much so that I cannot stop myself from coming up with new inventions.
I'll let you investigate a certain location.
It's something I would be very keen to hear your opinion on.
Oh, okay.
Alright, I'll do her stupid quest.
This is a long con.
I have to do this.
I have to be her muse so I can have him all to myself.
Alright.
Guys, this is...
This is just a long con.
Okay, now I can change.
Alright, let's see.
Where is my spear?
Alright.
Come on, come on.
Excuse me.
Guys, guys, excuse me.
I'm trying to... trying to get my fucking 200 kills here.
I'm in like Tau Tau's territory for some reason.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, let me get you out of the way.
You're annoying me.
There you go.
That's fine.
Let me get this general out of the way.
Alright.
Goddamn, stop!
Stop, chariot!
Bitch!
Alright.
Oh my god, like, I... he's just...
They're just riding around me.
There you go.
I destroyed one.
Nice.
Now we gotta destroy this one.
Okay.
Get over here.
What are you poking?
Come on.
Get over here.
Just drag me over here.
Nice.
Alright.
I'll just be over here.
Nice.
Easy.
How much more do I need?
Okay.
Very accurate fight.
They got it, like, hooked up to me.
Alright, I did your mission.
Also, how much more do I need for a dalion?
Stupid...
Thing.
That shit's taking so long.
Alright.
50 more and then I need more of that.
And I still need to do the perfect evade.
I'll do that next to a boss.
Yeah, I did.
Please allow me to visit you later.
To hear about it in detail.
Alright.
Nice, I did her thing.
Uh...
I need to do...
Guan Yun and Zhang Fei.
Blade of Honor.
Where is it?
Oh, there you go.
Challenged by Zhang Fei.
Alright, let's do it.
I don't know what he wants me to do.
But more than farm my XP for Riz.
My Riz-P.
Oh, it's to challenge him.
Okay.
You know what?
Let me use my new weapon.
I had one that was like...
Okay, 152.
Let's try this.
Alright.
This is gonna be interesting.
What?
Oh, it's a duel!
Oh, okay.
Let me swap weapons again.
Alright.
I didn't realize we're dueling.
Alright, goodbye.
Well, if we're dueling, this is a lot easier.
Okay, nice.
Alright, Zhang Fei.
Are you sure you still wanna keep dueling?
Are you sure?
I mean, I can keep going.
I can stop anytime, Zhang Fei.
Are you sure, buddy?
Alright.
You could've...
You should've asked for surrender.
But he just wanted to embarrass himself.
Alright.
Nice.
That was easy.
Thank you.
Duel more like slaughter.
Look, if he wants to embarrass himself in front of his generals, like, that's on him.
I gave him a chance to surrender.
Alright, nice.
Well, I kicked his ass when we first met.
You're no ordinary man.
That much is clear.
You're so dependable.
You almost put me to shame.
You stick with us all the way to the end.
Alright, now I have to do... I assume the next one is I fight Guan Yun, right?
The Blade of Honor?
What's this?
Level 35?
Yeah, no.
I'm too weak for that.
Where's Blade of Honor?
Ah!
Where the fuck is Blade of Honor?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I have to go back.
No, it wasn't near him.
It's like in another area.
Which is weird.
It's like somewhere here.
Yeah, it's like in this...
It's such a big territory, too.
Ah!
Alright.
The fuck is here?
Ah!
Is it here?
No.
Is it?
Oh, it is!
Blade of Honor.
There you go.
Okay, it's just people robbing.
Alright, that's fine.
Now I should be able to use my spear.
Alright, let's go.
Ah!
Alright.
This one's less about...
Okay, I have to help peasants reach the escape point.
That's fine.
There we go.
Get outta here!
Nice.
C'mon, Y!
Y!
The easiest combo there is!
Oh wait, I should...
I need to use this.
I keep forgetting this one is like with X and not... Alright.
Leave!
Easiest combo ever!
Sorry, no.
The hardest combo ever.
Alright.
We did!
Okay, we just did...
What the fuck did I just do?
I'm like... Alright, we did something.
Okay, now it's just this attack.
There we go.
I just gotta do this all the time.
I finished it.
Now it's gone.
Alright, we successfully...
Now we gotta do perfect evades, however that's done.
I still don't really know how to do that.
With attacks from a wheel recovery?
Fucking no.
Just like, ow.
Alright.
Let's go back to my wheelies.
Alright, let me see if I can do a perfect evade.
I don't know how, but let's see if I could.
Oh!
Wait, was that it?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Attack me!
Come on!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm farming this.
I'm farming this.
I'm farming it.
Oh no.
Wait, wait.
Okay, I did two.
Three!
Give me a sec, I'm gonna farm this.
Come on.
Oh shit, okay.
I didn't do it.
It's okay.
Four!
Oh shit.
It'll be fine, it'll be fine.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh shit!
Okay, okay.
I can't do it.
I just realized where I am.
Shit!
I'm coming back.
That's awkward.
Whoops.
I forgot about the peasants.
I forgot about...
Okay, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero.
Sorry, this was much more important.
Okay, there we go.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Open the door.
I had- Look, I had to farm!
There we go.
Don't worry!
Don't worry, I'm here!
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm here, guys, don't worry.
Don't worry, I'll farm him.
Oh shit, no!
Shit, no!
It's okay, I'm here now.
I'm here.
Guys, don't worry.
Oh no, I didn't do it.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, I need one more!
I need one more!
Typical Novo for getting up, but look, this was very important.
Wait.
Oh my god, I did it!
I did it!
Nice!
Okay, we fight for real.
We fight for real.
Alright, now kill him.
I did what I had to do.
I can kill him now.
See, look at that.
I'm a hero.
Dude, I... I saved them!
What do you mean?!
I did my thing!
I did my job.
I saved them.
I did what I had to do.
I'm a hero.
I wanna say that I'm a hero.
No way!
They're alive, okay?
They're alive.
Is that not enough?
Look at that.
Save what was left of them.
Look, I completed my missions, okay?
I completed my missions.
Yay!
Look at that.
Perfect event.
Alright,
nice.
What is this?
Oh shit, what?
I could be... Oh, I need 70 for that.
I should've fucking invested in this.
Alright, nice.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta go...
Wait, there's something over here.
What is over there?
Oh, is this the moongrass?
Oh no, it's the alpagrass.
Okay, nice.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Actually no, I don't have any actual missions though.
Duel, defeat 5, sword training...
Like, none of these other ones are that important, not gonna lie.
Yeah, they're like none of the ones that I want to seduce.
So I don't need to do it.
Alright, I need to go back home?
Alright, who do I... Yuan Hao?
No, I don't need to talk to you.
Oh, Guan Yu is over here.
Yeah, there you go.
Wait, Zhang Fei wants to talk again?
Oh, let's talk to Guan Yu first.
Yay!
Until then, it falls to the likes of us to win these small victories.
If for no reason, then to give people hope, a reason to live another day.
I hope you will share in my mission for as long as this righteousness lives within us.
We will have many more chances yet to make this world just a little better.
Alright, Zhang Fei.
We're bonding!
We're gonna bond!
You guys wanna watch us bond?
Outside?
At night?
Wanna see the flowers at night again?
It's nice here, isn't it?
Sure.
I like it here.
I do.
Then let's stay here a while.
I've been meaning to talk with you.
Under the stars?
Under the tree?
You've been doing a great job.
Where the flowers blossom?
My brothers have really started to depend on you.
Alright guys, grab a chair!
I'm glad I made all that effort to win you over to our side.
I'm glad I made all the effort to win you over to our side.
That was what convinced me, okay?
Really?
I'm glad to hear that.
Just you, Zhang Fei.
I've been thinking about that time a lot lately.
But you really like it here, don't you?
You've even started thinking of it as home?
You've already become one of us.
I'm waiting for Zhuge Liang.
I'm waiting for him.
From now on, you're part of the family.
That's how much you've come to mean to us.
I'm not here for them.
I'm here for Zhuge Liang.
I don't know what better off than we were.
There's still more work to be done.
The three of us always live life on the edge.
Will you remain by our side?
For us all?
Now, a straight talker.
I like that.
Alright, let's enjoy the rest of the night.
Let's make a promise.
If either of us gets injured, the other has to nurse the dead to health.
Fade to black.
Why me?
I do not have the medical license to nurse you back together.
I am not... I do not have the license to take care of you.
I don't know how to fucking sew a wound.
Interpreting doctor.
Please tell me your secrets.
I have a favor to ask of you.
You possess knowledge regarding the secrets of a variety of weaponry.
Can I ask you to teach me what you know?
You're the only one I can ask such a thing.
This is you alone who have accepted everything above.
Yes!
I am taking Zhuge Liang's place.
She will not fall in love with him.
Yes!
She only has eyes for me now.
Alright.
Wait!
Might I visit you tonight?
Given our shared history, you might wonder why I wrote you this request.
But it's precisely because of our history that I wish to meet.
I'm doing like back to back to back to back.
We're missing right now.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't know if I have enough energy.
My body is weak, but my mind is strong.
I just need more water, guys.
I hope to talk with you in detail and at length about the days we've spent together and the memories we've shared.
I look forward to seeing you.
The flesh is weak, but the spirit is willing.
Oh, there he is.
Who do I talk to?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're both waiting for me outside.
Okay, Guanyin first.
Guanyin first.
Keep hydrating, you got a busy night.
Oh my god.
This place has the feeling of a second home.
Talking with you always brings me such irreplaceable joy.
Okay.
The only thing that gives him joy.
Our friendship has withstood quite the test of time.
Friendship?
Is that what you call it?
Something inside me knew that would be the case on the moment we first met in Ji province.
I thought the same, Guanyin.
Our bond is undeniable, to be sure.
Now that I think about it, we fought together with Zheng Zhao back then.
Taking the leader of the Yellow Turbans as an ally, punishing government officials.
What wild tribulations fate had in store for us.
I'll never forget that day, Guanyin.
You and I on the battlefield.
After the battle, the two of us.
Though we parted ways with Zheng Zhao, you and I have long had our eyes fixed on the same goal.
Side by side, to the deftest part, I'm pretty sure you'll die first.
Let's not talk about him, just talk about you and I.
It's no exaggeration to say, I consider it a blessing from the heavens.
You will play an essential part in Li Bei's campaign.
I believe that's actually true.
I've known you longer than even my sworn brothers.
Your comrade like no other.
Your presence fills me with confidence.
I'll make every effort for you.
Hearing such determination from you was so deeply moved.
May your wings of righteousness spread wide, my friend.
Let us continue to work together.
To ponder together.
And on occasion, spread our wings together.
After that, we shall ensure that Liu Bei accomplishes great things.
I see.
So that weapon's power comes from there.
An interesting insight indeed.
Thank you once again for your wisdom.
Um... could we speak for a little while longer?
There is something I wanted to talk about with an experienced warrior like you.
Yes, of course.
Thank you.
Your kindness is much appreciated.
Earlier, I mentioned that I want to create things that will make people's lives easier.
Where I'm from, there is a chronic shortage of laborers due to the war.
So, I designed and created a wooden doll.
A wooden- she made a robot?!
She did a Boston robot?!
So it was quite rudimentary.
It could only make a dough-pounding motion.
What the- witch!
At first, there were people who were happy to see it.
The old robot.
Saying it helped with their daily cooking.
In ancient China.
One day, officials came unannounced.
Oh my god!
She's like, witchcraft!
Get rid of the robot!
The Magistrate's office had received complaints that the doll moved using some suspicious device.
When the officials were getting ready to leave with the doll parts, they said this.
If you're going to build such a thing, you ought to make it able to wield a weapon.
And fight.
I was shocked.
I couldn't fathom that there were people who didn't like what I had made.
And those who wished to- The device of the devil!
Demon!
Using it as a weapon?
Well...
Those who fight wars always demand the most advanced inventions available.
In the end...
Apparently, my doll was rebuilt.
What the fuck?
And deployed as a weapon.
When?
I only found out because someone came to me to complain that it was useless in battle.
Yeah, it was made out of wood!
I was glad to hear that.
It made me realize...
My inventions could be used to hurt someone.
Like, what the fuck is that wooden doll going to do in battle?
Against, like, knives and swords?
But with those who misuse it.
That's why I have come to the decision to study weaponry.
So that I can continue working on my inventions.
Instead of dismissing research into weapons as a waste...
I'll try to learn everything I can in order to create a better future.
I like that.
I am a man with few words.
You do!
After she, like, poured her entire heart and soul into this conversation.
I like that.
He went, thumbs up.
Oh jeez.
I reacted to her conversation with thumbs up.
That's okay.
That means you get less time which you got there.
Sure, I'll stay.
What?
What are you gonna do with a life-sized doll of me?
Oh,
she's a funky freak.
What is she gonna do with a very accurate life-sized doll of me?
What parts does that include?
What does it include?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't remember agreeing to that.
No, it is not an anime pillow.
It is a type of... the first inventor of a sex doll.
I can't believe...
Recorded in history.
She measured it.
Jesse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, it was my birthday yesterday.
Can I get some birthday wishes?
And if we didn't battle, I promise to tend each other's wounds.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jesse.
Yeah, happy birthday!
Ever since we spoke the other day, I can't stop thinking about you.
Or rather, the untapped well of knowledge you possess.
As it happens, I have another investigation I need help with.
And I'd like to spend as much time as possible going over the results with you.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's do this, unfortunately.
Alright, here we go.
The Dragons, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
As a fellow Three Kingdoms fanboy, I greatly appreciate the Three Kingdoms streams.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so happy you've been joining them.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Can't wait to put them to use.
Alright, let's get him out of here.
Alright, what are the weapons?
What weapons are they?
Is it the horse?
Oh, it's the chariot.
Bro, it's the same weapon!
It's literally the same weapon!
I don't understand!
Alright, that's fine.
I can kill him.
Alright, we just gotta have the other weapon to show up.
There you go.
Nice.
Get out of here.
Alright, I need to kill you for extra XP.
No!
My XP!
Goddammit.
I needed to kill him for XP, man.
He had more.
Literally, the weapon stood in front of me.
The weapons just had to be in range.
Okay, chariot with your lance.
Nice, level up.
Alright, plus three.
Alright, Union.
I did the thing.
Sword are really easy.
Nice, more coins.
I'd like to talk to you, but would you mind if I came to see you?
We...
We just talked.
You haven't...
Alright.
Okay, she wants to talk again.
I was just with you!
What more do you want from me?
Oh my god, my body is weak, but my spirit is strong.
Alright, let's talk to my doctor first before we do anything.
I gotta make sure that I'm medically okay for this.
I don't think I had rest yet.
I gotta make sure...
I gotta make sure that my doctor approves before I go back in.
Am I training?
Are these the other guardians?
Yeah.
Yeah, what are you trying to do?
But he's just a child!
No, stay as you are, Ziluan.
Are we gonna kill a child?
We are bound to bring peace to the realm, to protect it.
We are not here to serve the Han, least of all when it would require handing over an innocent child to be protected.
Yeah, I was gonna say, as a child.
We know that.
But if we don't give them this child, every man and woman in this village will suffer the same fate.
So instead of doing what's right, you'd rather live in a world where the Han completely disobey you?
Okay, but how does he know?
We just cut his hair.
We cut his hair and they won't know.
There was once a hermit who helped Emperor Gaozu found the Han dynasty.
That hermit was our forefather, the original guardian of peace.
His goal was to find those who possessed the right qualities and teach them how to preserve peace in the realm.
It was never to submit to the whims of a dying kingdom, to slaughter the weak and those deemed enemies by virtue of their birth.
The Han is in its death throes.
It cannot be saved.
Okay, so the original guardian of peace failed his fucking job.
He did not do his job.
We must find the hero of this age and bring peace back to this land.
Come, let us talk to the chief.
Together, we can decide what should be done.
Yeah, like we just cut the child's hair.
How- there's so many like children back then, like orphans.
Like how would he know that's the child they're looking for?
And the sky is growing dark.
I always knew it wouldn't end with the village's destruction.
Jin Luan, this is your last chance to turn back.
Turn back what?
This may sound strange coming from the one who set you on this path, but what awaits you is likely a past- But the death of a child?
I killed so many.
One child is not gonna change anything.
I will force you to do anything that you don't want to.
Least of all for my benefit.
I will- you're telling me this now after all the fucking incense you put me on?
I was like, you choked me up so hard and now you tell me.
Oh yeah, you should have told me this before you put me on fucking- all these experimental herbs.
My father never could.
I thought that, perhaps that I could finally claim to have surpassed my father, the man they called a saint.
In the end, this has all been for my own selfish ends.
Forgive me.
Maybe it would have been better if you had never met me.
Oh, 100%.
It's you who wants to confront your past.
I set you on that course, and I cannot turn away from you now.
This is my responsibility, and I will not abandon it.
No, you literally live with me for free.
Like, all you've done is just give me, like, herbs.
That's right.
It's a rare herb that only grows naturally in same province.
If anyone can find it, you can.
Alright, another herb.
I haven't had fan mail in so long.
Where are my old ancient dragoons?
Oh my god.
Please tell me your secrets.
Please tell me more of your secrets.
How much do you want from- Can I ask you to humor me?
I- I literally just talked to you.
Oh my god.
We- we just talked, like, five minutes ago.
I'd like for you to teach me more secrets about building weaponry.
You're the only one I can ask for this, and there are a lot of other things I'd like to do with this.
You will not be possible until we meet in person, so as soon as you're ready, I'll come to your room.
I'm sure that this will be-
I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I need to refill my water.
I need to hydrate before she shows up to my room.
Alright.
Alright, I have more water.
I gotta make sure I'm hydrated.
Before she shows up.
I got it.
Oh man, SimpleMind, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How many times has DookieRit laughed this stream?
I just got here.
DarkFlame, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Her first mistake was not putting a copyright on her robot concept.
I'm just saying, did the robot not do enough?
You literally have a life-size, very accurate robot of me.
And now she's gonna show up in my room, guys.
I have something to tell you about.
It's about Arbor Green.
The plant I had you find me the other day.
It actually has some rather rare benefits.
According to the warish raving, it can improve one's powers of observation, insight for a time, and this in turn leads to enhancement of the effects of training.
Apparently, you can even buy some of them these days if you can afford the high price.
So how about giving it a try?
No, I'll still forage.
Oh my god.
The fact that she was like, I'm gonna show up in your room.
And we're gonna make some memories.
Holy shit.
I was not ready for that.
I was not ready for that at all.
No, your active eyes will affect... I'll just make one then.
There we go.
Alright, where is she?
Oh sorry, I forgot.
Where is she?
Wait, where is she?
She said she'll show up in my room.
Where is she?
This?
No, that's moon grass.
Where is she?
She said she'll show up.
I'm scared.
She said she'll show up in my room.
Oh, she's over here.
Okay, that's not where I live, but that's okay.
There she is.
Alright.
Hello.
Guys, don't.
It's a long con, guys.
I'll be the only one in her mind.
And then Jugodlan will be mine.
Are you feeling okay?
What is it?
That's good.
Guys, that's good.
I hope you stay there for the rest of your life.
She needs to stay there for the rest of her life and she'll never meet him.
That's good!
Let's go!
It's all coming together.
You understand me.
You taught me about so many things that I never knew existed.
Not just weapons, but also feelings.
What?
I'm sorry.
I know I shouldn't be saying this out loud.
Actually, once I returned home, I was thinking about channeling these emotions to start my work on that thing we talked about.
Wait, which one?
There were many things.
Which one?
You wanted to create a lot of things.
I promised to show you the greatest replica of yourself that you've ever seen.
You make us laugh.
I love you.
Oh my god.
I look forward to it.
And I'm passionate as always.
Oh, she's the most accurate doll I've ever seen.
I don't even know what to say.
What do I say to that?
Passionate as always.
Oh my god.
I don't think this was in history.
I did it.
Jukka who to her?
She won't have him in here.
Wait, she's getting closer.
I did it, guys.
They won't get married now.
I did it, everyone.
I've completed my mission.
I've denied their marriage.
I've changed the fate.
I've changed fate.
This was all worth it, guys.
It was all worth it.
I've changed fate.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
You know, YuYan might have built life-sized doll of you, but at least she didn't spend trillions on a home sub.
That's different.
She literally invented the world's first sex doll.
Because she was that desperate.
Alan, Nepper, Salad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
According to... The Host Club is a good investment, guys.
According to the tutorial, to eliminate Yuan Shu...
We were supposed to advance our forces to attack his headquarters, but the situation has changed.
Yuan Shu's force...
I like... I'm fucking sure that has to be made up for this game.
Like, YuYan did not make a fucking life-sized Acura doll of a person.
I refuse to believe it.
I refuse to believe she actually did this.
The enemy is led by Li Qian.
We fought him both in Xiao Pei.
Let's make sure we drive him right back, just like last time.
Let me remind you that we'll be commanding our forces in this fight.
As always, I'll need your protection to make sure that I'm not defeated.
Our vast... The enemy outnumbered us greatly, but when do they not?
It is actually rather fortunate that we're now on the defensive.
Let's use our positioning to overcome their advantage.
We'll have no trouble riding them in confusion, but to make this work, they may need to be lured north and south.
A strong central defense should be our first priority.
We have to make them believe they won't get through easily.
Alright.
They don't have to... We won't let you down.
Every time a fight comes my way, I rely on my companions to get through it.
Having all of you with me is what makes me believe I can win.
It is honored to have each of you by my side.
Alright, I'm ready.
We don't even need to use the traps.
I'm going straight in.
Alright.
Let's go.
Get over here!
As long as you... As long as, like, you know...
Aw man, if Yuya and Jugo then actually get together and then they use my fucking very accurate doll in their freaky adventures, I don't know how I'll feel.
They'll be like, guys, we need to spice up this marriage.
And then she brings out the doll.
Also, after this battle, guys, I gotta walk dad.
I gotta do, like, a dad walk after this.
Alright, nice.
Let me just kill all of these guys real quick.
I gotta let off some steam.
Please, keep me back in the battlefield.
I don't...
He's like, walkies!
What the fuck?
Why is this fucking nerd doing so much to me?
Get out of here!
I've been... I've been risking so much that my body doesn't remember how to fight.
I've been too busy risking.
I forgot how to fight.
My body is so tired.
You don't understand.
Alright, we got rid of him.
Oh wait, there's more?
Alright, I'll get rid of him.
Alright, nice.
An opening!
There's so many openings!
I'm just very dehydrated right now.
What do I do now?
I did it.
Wait, what do I do now?
Wait, what?
Who did he kill?
Oh, I should get this guy.
Okay, this way.
Oh wait, the trap!
Okay, yeah, I should let them do the trap thing.
Wait, where is he?
Alright, I'll let them do the trap first.
But I'll kill him first.
It'll be fine.
What do we do?
Alright, nice.
Okay, now I go back to F.
Don't worry!
They can't activate the traps if I kill all of them!
Get over here!
Wait, reinforcements?
Wait, excuse me?
What do you mean reinforcements?
Alright, give me a sec.
I'll come over.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit!
What?!
I stopped you!
Oh shit!
Alright.
Wait, they're advancing towards me?!
Oh, they're scared.
They're so scared.
Oh my god, the guard has fled?!
Who fled?!
What do you mean you guys fled?!
How did you guys leave?!
What do you mean you guys left?!
Guys, we're still fighting!
The fight literally just started!
You can't just leave!
I left.
You can't do anything about it.
Alright, we got rid of him.
I was gonna say, we literally just started!
Okay.
Alright, CHARGE!
Are you kidding?
Does he want to challenge me?
Wait, who is he?
Am I supposed to know who you are?
I was like, who is he?
I don't even know who you are!
Alright, get over here.
I don't know who you are, but I'll still kick your ass.
Wait, is this the commander?!
Oh my god, already?!
Alright, we'll get rid of you now.
Oh wait, you are!
Okay.
Good, you came to me.
That's good.
I don't have to like...
I don't have to travel to you.
Get over here so I can go back to my real game.
HAHAHA!
Let me kill you so I can go back to the actual game.
My Ryuzing.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
He's like halfway.
Jesus Christ, you have so much HP.
Oh my god!
How do you still...
I'm only halfway!
Alright, nice.
I'm just gonna...
Alright.
Encouragement!
Go!
Cheer them on!
Alright.
Spin!
Retaining game.
All I'm saying is I need to kill him so I can go back to what really matters.
In this game.
The Ryuz.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
What is he doing?
Why is he sending bubbles out?
HAHAHA!
What do the bubbles mean?
What do the bubbles mean?!
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
OH FUCK!
OH GOD!
OH SHIT!
Okay, that's what the bubble means guys.
That's what they mean, I just realized.
He's literally what...
I was like, what do they mean?
Wait, he wasn't the boss?
Wait, he wasn't the end game?
Oh my god, why do they all have so much HP?
Guan Yu.
Guan Yu, I'm not okay.
I missed.
I missed!
Oh my god.
Guys.
GUYS!
I'M NOT OKAY!
Oh my god, where's... where's the house?
Where's the house?
I'm 1 HP.
I need buns.
I need buns real quick guys.
Oh, where's the buns at?
Oh my god, okay.
Snack break.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the actual fight.
It's okay, I'm okay now.
I got my snacky break.
Oh my god, who the fuck did I fight that did so much?
Okay.
We're fine.
Round 2.
Jesus Christ.
Nice.
Alright.
We did it.
Okay, we gotta go home now.
Oh shit!
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
Let me kill this one random guy first.
Liu Bei will be fine.
He'll live.
Don't worry, I'll be there soon.
I just need to kill this one guy.
I need the XP.
Guys, don't worry.
He'll live.
Oh my god.
Liu Bei, please just live for one second.
Please.
Liu Bei.
Liu Bei, live for one second.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
Liu Bei, please.
Please do a level guide.
Please.
He didn't realize we were there.
Oh my god.
He is so weak.
You were at half HP.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
He was half HP, guys.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to get my buttons again.
Snacky break.
Guys, snack break.
Give me a sec.
It's snacky break right now.
Wow.
Okay.
Okay, I'm grabbing my snack break and then...
I'll kill him and then I'll go straight... Okay, I learned my lesson, guys.
I learned my lesson this time.
I learned my lesson.
Okay.
This time, I got it.
I just kill him and then it'll be fine.
Snack break, take 3.
Don't worry.
It'll be fine.
Okay.
We're almost done.
Don't worry.
Please, do not die.
I'm almost done, Liu Bei!
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead, okay.
I'm coming over.
Please, I swear to God.
I'm skipping him.
I'm skipping him this time.
Are you serious?
Are you half HP?
How are you half HP?
Liu Bei, I swear to God, I can't get to you.
Liu Bei, I swear!
I swear to God, I couldn't even get to him.
So, like, give me a sec.
Okay.
Like, I am trying my best.
I am trying my best right now.
Liu Bei, I don't understand.
How are you so weak?
I don't understand.
Oh my God.
How is he so weak?
How is my buddy so fucking weak?
Jesus Christ.
I'm doing everything I can.
I'm doing everything I can right now.
To make sure he lives.
He's just so weak.
Oh my God, they're all too far from me.
A breakdance.
He's just a ball.
What?
How?
How do I save you?
Why are you so weak?
Oh my God.
Okay.
Snacky break, take two.
I died.
I couldn't even get my snack break.
I couldn't even get my food break.
Oh my God.
Alright.
Alright, here we go again.
Fun break.
Break for my buns.
Right here.
Okay, we're not doing XP anymore.
We're going straight to save it.
Making sure Lupe does not get involved.
Alright.
Okay, I just need to block him.
As long as he...
Alright.
Look at me.
Don't go over.
Just come to me.
There we go.
As long...
He doesn't...
Okay, there we go.
We can do this.
There we go.
As long as he doesn't go to Lupe, it should be fine.
It should be fine.
What?
This is the only way.
It's okay.
I've distracted them from going into the actual fight.
It's fine.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know what's going on.
Just don't go there.
Okay.
It's fine.
I'm like somewhere in here.
I don't...
Holy shit.
Like, what do I do?
Please.
Oh, no.
I just need one Musou.
Nice.
It's rage time.
You shall not pass.
It's okay.
It's rage mode.
As long as I keep hitting...
I can get my HP back with this.
I can get my HP back.
I'll kill this random general.
It's okay.
I'm getting it back.
It might have been a waste of my rage, but like, I need anything I can get right now.
Oh, my God.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I killed one.
I got a little bit of it back, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay, nice.
Alright, use your move.
Please.
I'm almost close to beating Guan Yu.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
I'm full HP.
It's possible.
It's actually possible.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
I dodged.
Nice.
Cancel.
It's fine.
See?
I did it.
I just need to make sure they don't touch Liu Bei.
And it'll be fine.
Alright, nice.
Do the twirl.
Guys, I think I need more money so I can actually buy a weapon.
My lack of money is actually fucking me over.
I should have not went to so many host clubs, guys.
Like, I think it actually is fucking me over.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Please.
I can almost become Guan Yin.
I'm so close.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Gotta do the twirl.
Where is he?
Nice.
He's so close to dying.
God damn it.
All my guards are dead.
Nice.
Counter!
He's 1 HP.
Yeah!
We did it!
You're just building carry.
All that risk and no power.
We did it!
Woo!
Ba da dum ba da da da da da!
Yeah, that was incredibly close, Liu Bei.
That was a little bit too close, Liu Bei.
Alright, nice.
Level 16.
Yay!
We did it!
I only regret that I could not slay Yuan Shu.
He will not survive our next encounter.
Just another raging victory for the Liu Bei army.
Just as planned.
Just Liu Bei almost dying yet again.
At least I haven't heard anything of concern.
Liu Bei!
Wait.
Is that...
Oh yeah, I forgot about the third brother.
Hey guys, remember Zhang Fei?
Zhang Fei?
What are you doing here?
Oh yeah, Lu Bu took over the castle.
We are drinking!
Zhang Fei!
I knew it.
That's why you should never leave a drunk to guard a castle.
You were told not to drink, bro!
Why were you drinking?!
That doesn't answer my question!
Classic Liu Bu.
Silly man.
Little rascal.
Yeah, we lost like 80% of our army there.
With Liu Bei's brilliant plan.
I will be cruel to the people there.
Fighting him now gains us nothing.
But...
As much as I hate to admit it, losing Xiao Pei is something of a relief.
It's a weight off my shoulders.
Until now, I have forged my path with an unrelenting determination to help those in need.
Did I make the right choices?
Or have I gone astray?
What does it truly mean to make the world a better place?
I... still do not know.
But...
If there are answers to these questions...
Then perhaps I can find them within someone like Lord Liu Bu.
We should prepare to withdraw.
What do you mean?
Are we still gonna rely on him?
Bro, that guy just betrayed us!
What do you mean find answers with him?
It's all my fault.
If I hadn't lost control of the castle, he'd never be talking like this.
Oh no, he's going through a midlife crisis, guys.
Oh no, you broke him, Zhang Fei!
Look what you did!
You broke our brother!
Duck, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
She did, but it was broken within the first week.
Hence why no one remembered it.
Wait, how did she break the dog?
And moved his stronghold to Xiao Pi once more.
Alright.
He betrayed us.
Yes, this is your fault!
Yes!
You broke him!
Look what you did!
You broke that man!
He had nothing!
Yeah, we lost the entire castle.
He wasn't even drinking outside of town.
He was drinking in the castle and he still manages to lose the castle.
I'll go talk to him.
Yeah, I don't think
he wants to see you, Zhang Fei.
Oh no, he's drinking too.
He's drinking his sorrows away.
Oh no, he's at the pub.
Alright, do I have enough yet?
Goddammit, okay.
Oh my god, Dragoon's Destiny.
Oh my god, okay, I need to get this.
Oh my god, we're so close to being able to afford it!
Alright, let's sell this.
Alright,
we're so close.
We can almost afford it, guys.
We can afford it now!
Nice!
Alright, see guys, I don't only spend it on host clubs.
See guys, I spend it on real things too.
Oh my god, it's been so long, I finally got my ye olde super chat.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Wow, thank you so much, buddy.
Alright, so I'll light.
I'll do one.
Alright, let's see.
Alright guys, I'm gonna walk dad real quick, okay?
It's his walkie time.
And we are doing a long stream, so I have to use that time to walk him.
Alright, walking my dog.
Be right back.
Alright, here we go.
Here, you can watch my doctor doing doctor things.
Here we go, just walking my dog.
I'll be right back.
Alright,
I'm back guys.
I'm back from walkies.
I don't know how Doki and Badoge does it.
But every time, every time he knows it's like, I need to be like back in time.
He like, does long, he wants long walkies.
He's like, you think I'm just gonna poop once?
No, no, no, no.
This is gonna be a twofer.
And then he always does the thing where like, I walk away from the trash can.
And then he's like, you wanna walk back?
You want me to walk back?
You wanna walk back and throw away the second dump?
Alright, I already forgot.
Oh yeah, I had to talk to Lube real quick.
I gotta get him from the pub.
Alright Lupe, I'm gonna pick you up from the pub.
But before I do that, let me like, fix my weapon real quick.
Uh, where are the new ones?
I don't even fucking know.
Where are the new ones that I received?
A Tempest Dance?
Woah.
What the, what the fuck is this?
Like, what the, okay, so...
Which one denies?
I assume this one...
That prevents staggering when using.
Okay, um...
I don't know what to use.
All of these are fucking crazy.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of that.
No, I'm gonna get rid of that and put in a Tempest Dance.
That's crazy.
I summon a fucking tornado.
I'm using that shit.
Alright, uh...
That shit, alright.
Lupe, your brothers want me to pick you up from the pub.
Your brothers are worried.
Yeah, it's me.
He's at rock bottom.
Oh no, don't worry.
Don't worry.
When your son is born, then we'll see rock bottom.
Indulge me and listen for a moment.
It feels like it's been a lifetime since I left Yo.
And yet it has passed in the blink of an eye.
I only picked up a weapon because I was tired of seeing the sadness...
There's more!
Don't worry, you can fall even down, like, you can fall even more.
Don't worry, buddy.
This is not your rock bottom.
Far higher than I could ever possibly deserve.
I said I wanted to accomplish great things.
But that doesn't mean I want to sit in a castle and look down on others.
If Lord Louie Boo will protect the people of Shrew...
Then that is good enough for me.
Are you sure?
Are you sure that's all you want?
Well, I think so, but...
Are you sure you want Lou Boo to be in charge?
The guy that's known for murdering people?
Yeah?
The murderer?
Bro, he's not as midlife crisis yet.
He still doesn't have a mustache.
Hello!
Recent defeat?
I killed him!
What?!
Look, we might have lost 80% of our army, but I still killed him.
You stabbed us in the back!
You were drinking!
So this time, why don't you do the fighting and leave the guard duty to us?
And now you taunt us with a promise of betrayal.
Perhaps I should kill you all while I still have the chance.
You're welcome to try!
Stop!
This is complicated enough.
So what's the plan then?
You're just going to join forces with these traitors?
Calm down.
They are neither friends nor foes.
Lord Tao Qian has tasked us with the protection of Shu.
And as long as Yuan Shu maintains his position at Shou Chun, Shu will be vulnerable to attack.
Therefore, I have decided that we will assist you in defeating his forces.
Brother!
I don't know.
I feel like every time we let him decide what to do with the army, it has not really gone well.
I just feel like maybe we should stop letting him decide what to do.
Someone should really stop him.
It's getting a bit of a problem now.
Alright, let's see.
Let's see if there's anybody at the...
Let's see if there's anyone that requests me at the host club.
This is important, guys.
Oh, nobody.
Okay.
No one wants... Okay, that's okay.
That's okay.
That gives me more time to save money.
I just wanted to save money anyway.
It's okay, guys.
I wanted to save my money.
Like, that's good.
That's good.
Guys, that's good.
I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with that, guys.
I'm fine.
Alright, is this what I need?
Oh, I got the Crimson Crest.
Oh wait, I can get...
Get that incense one last time.
Let me get that incense in me one last time before we go.
Alright, nice.
Let's go.
Let's head over.
One last ride.
Time for the good stuff.
Time to relax before I go murder people again.
I thought Bai Long is the chief.
What?
Just cut his hair.
Cut his hair!
How do I cope with killing millions of people?
I don't know, but light up that incense, baby.
That means those two died?
Yeah?
So what happened to those two?
Yeah, but I don't know what's real or not.
Like, is she actually...
Alive or is she just my visions?
My incense visions?
Because I'm the only one that sees these two, too.
Like, no one else sees them.
Like, she's next to me and I'm like, do you see her?
And then my doctor was like, I don't know, but you want a stronger incense?
Innocence?
I thought you were one of the strongest warriors.
I've been told they were a proud people.
The truth is, there was never any reason to tie yourself to the village.
You mean I could just leave?
You always had the means to leave.
Wait, what the fuck?
I could just leave?
You have the freedom to fly far, far away from this place.
Wherever your destiny might lead you.
I want to go on that journey with you and Bai Long, too.
Into a world of peace.
Peace, okay.
Okay, this woman does not know what's outside this world.
What the fuck do you mean, peace?
I literally left the village and there's like a fucking war and famine going on.
Oh my god, surely a world outside this village is better.
Does she know?
Your treatment is going quite well.
I think we may soon see the day that your memory is completely restored.
Try to find some thistle done.
They say it grows in Yang province.
It's a rare commodity, but I have faith in your abilities.
Oh my god, there's more.
I thought that was the last one.
What the fuck does she mean, peace?
I went out of this village and I murdered so many people.
It must be so peaceful outside.
Alright, get to the camp.
Hello.
Wait, will they grow mustaches?
I feel like I'm talking to boys.
Little boys.
Where are my mustachioed men?
Their faces are naked.
Me too, I'm leaving.
God.
It's just wrong to see Tao Tao and Liu Bei without a mustache.
It's just weird.
It's so weird.
Especially Tao Tao.
I feel like Tao Tao, if anybody, should be the one that should have had a mustache.
It's okay.
It's okay, it makes it more exciting.
It's a nice thought, but...
It's like Romeo and Juliet, one guy.
Last time we were together.
Okay.
Is that it?
Was that interaction just because that guy misses me?
Oh shit.
I'm watching from the corner.
Guys, do you see the tension right now?
Oh my god.
Oh.
And yet, I can't get you out of my mind.
Oh my god.
And you kept saying in my mind.
Bro, he's saying you fell off, Liu Bei.
You fell off, bro!
Tao Tao's just like, I still thought I saw you as an equal.
Now you're lower than me.
And I'm not into that.
He's like, I am not into that, man.
Alright, I got another letter.
Okay.
I just did.
You want me to do more?
Alright.
Alright, 35.
I am not level 35, but that's okay.
I think, oh man, I don't know now.
I'm a little scared.
Maybe I can do this one level.
I'll do this one level and I should be level 35, right?
Okay, this is level 29.
Alright.
No, I'm a little worried.
I'm a little worried doing above my level.
Alright, let's use the dragoon.
The dragoon thing.
Wait, what do I have to kill?
The bandits?
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
No way!
I'm coming for him!
Alright, tornado time!
Holy shit!
Wait, this- what the fuck?
Okay, that shit's strong.
Oh my god, I killed 700 people already.
Okay.
Tornado, face the wrath!
Okay, I was not expecting 700 already.
Alright.
Alright, tornado time!
Tornado!
Nice, goodbye.
Alright, I should be at- I should be close to level 35, right?
Alright, it's tornado time again.
Wait, I already used up all of it.
Okay, no tornado time.
Unfortunate.
Oh wait, it's tornado time!
Woo!
Oh shit.
Okay, don't worry.
I still got him.
Goodbye.
Spin the wind.
Spin!
Alright, time to fight the actual boss.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Get over here.
Oh, I have to kill 700!
Oh, that's my entire mission!
I'm sorry, I didn't read.
You guys know that.
I'm not here to read.
I've only killed like 400.
Alright.
Ew.
It's fine.
Spin!
Nice.
He's spinning!
Wait, why is he not spinning?
I'm gonna say, what's the point?
I just want you to spin!
Alright, get over here.
It's time to spin.
Spin!
Oh shit.
He's spinning!
Nice.
Alright, that should kill him soon, right?
Oh, armor or bo- wait, let's just kill him then.
Spin!
Where did he go?
I just spun so- I was like, what the fuck?
Where did he spin to?
It's fine.
Alright.
Oh shit.
I didn't remember like, what the cancel moves are for this one.
Nice, we did it.
Come on, I just need 200 more.
Where are the rest?
Alright, we gotta go this way.
He spun too fast, I was like, where'd he go?
Alright, it's spinning time!
Alright.
Spin!
Holy fuck!
Where did they all go?
Whoops.
Nice.
That should be everybody.
Okay, no, we still have yet to kill.
Oh nice, okay, the general has finally arrived.
Alright, nice.
It's all about sending a message.
Thank you, you guys like- you guys like that?
You guys like that?
How I didn't kill anybody?
Yeah?
Spin!
Get over here.
Spin again!
Just keep spinning!
I just need to kill one more and I'm done.
Alright, now I just have to kill him.
And then you keep spinning.
Spinning my tornado.
It's raining, man.
I'll just keep using that.
He's like, where am I?
Alright, nice.
You think I'm gonna stop?
You never stop spinning.
Spinning.
I refuse to ever let you stop.
Spin!
Let's do something!
She's using magic!
Somebody stop her!
Nice.
Yay!
It's mine now.
Alright.
Swing your spear to generate whirlwind around you.
Okay.
I don't need that.
I already have what I need.
Okay, nice.
Do I do anything else?
No?
Yeah, magic isn't against the rules.
Void Town, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What flavor would you like your smoothie to be?
What?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Am I...
Oh, nice.
See?
Look at that.
I leveled up twice.
See, guys?
All I had to do was spin.
Oh, because they were in the blender!
I get it!
Loli, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
So Doki, about Yu Yan's perfect Doki doll, wasn't her first invention something that...
Currently marching towards Shou Chun at the behest of Lord Lubu.
This is in accordance with the Imperial decree to bring down Yuan Shu.
Yuan Shu is a powerful threat to Shu province, even without orders from the Emperor.
We'd still have to deal with him eventually.
What?
Jesus Christ, like...
Can you bring more people?
Like...
Lu Bei, why do you never bring enough?
Like, I don't understand.
I'm not merely acting on the whims of Lord Lubu alone.
Brother, you've been acting strange since your return from Tao Tao's camp.
Is something he said to you troubling your thoughts?
Ah, no.
I'm fine.
It's nothing.
For this battle, our side has formed an alliance of three forces.
Tao Tao, Sun Tzu, and Lord Lubu.
Each commander must survive or...
Okay, I have to protect four people.
Okay.
Alright, that's cool.
I have to protect all four of them and hope they don't die.
Okay, that's cool.
Meanwhile, Sun Tzu's forces will be attacking from the east.
Their plan is to use Siege Tower to scale the castle walls.
The success of both strategies will be critical to storming the castle.
But we should also render aid on the eastern front as much as possible.
I think that's all there is to discuss now.
Just charging into battle at Lubu's...
Okay, Guan Yu.
This is all we've been doing.
Nothing is different.
Even if Lubu is telling us to do it, we've done this since Lu Bei was commanding us.
Do you really wish to know, Guan Yu?
Well, I'd be lying if I said I didn't have...
Like, that's not different from any other strategy Lu Bei has done.
Like, all we've done is just charge in.
I don't understand.
Different leaders, same strategy.
Like, nothing has changed.
Clearly, nothing has changed in this strategy.
We're still doing the same thing we've always done.
And now he's like, are you sure this is a good idea?
Not that Lubu's the fucking leader.
Look, none of this was ever a good idea.
Like, I hate to say it.
None of it was ever good.
Spin!
This is the only move I know how to do.
Yes!
This is the only thing I know how to do now.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Get outta here!
Stereo.
Easy.
We got the base.
Now we leave.
Open the gates!
Alright, we fight.
Alright, let's go.
That's fine, I can do that.
I have one move only.
And it has worked so far.
Okay, I don't know how I got fucking collapsed, but that's okay.
This one move has always worked for me.
Alright, encourage!
Alright.
I don't know where anybody is.
Alright, let's beat up this old man first.
That's fine.
You know what this means!
Okay, we have to do this fast.
Alright, you know what to do!
Oh shit!
You know- Oh, I can't do it, nevermind.
Nevermind.
Jesus Christ, where is he?
I don't know if I like the spear, guys.
I think like...
Okay, actually I do- No!
The one thing I look forward to in life!
And he fucking denied it!
He interrupted it with a giant fucking rock!
I'm so sad.
What is that?
Full chariot charge?
Who do I kill?
Destroy the two chariots.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me beat up this old man real quick.
Alright, where are they?
Alright, there he is.
Okay, I need him to get closer.
Hey, can the chariot get a little closer to me?
It sucks.
Okay, give me a sec.
They're riding- Please, I'm trying so hard to get closer to the chari- Oh my god, please!
I'm trying!
Bro, okay.
This is actually- Okay, guys.
I am trying my hardest to get as close as I can to these chariots.
Like, he's just- Like, he's not letting me near him.
Oh my god, there we go.
We got one.
Okay.
Okay, this is bad.
This is so bad.
I can't see!
Where am I?!
Oh my god!
Where is the other chari- Where am I?!
Oh my god.
Where is the other chariot?
Where is the other chariot?!
I can't see!
What?
Oh my god, there it is.
Okay, we gotta head over there.
I'm literally in tro- Okay, we did it.
I don't know where it is.
We did it.
I actually- I don't know how I did it.
I don't know how we did it, but we did it.
Like, there's so many people here.
I'm so lost.
I'm actually so lost right now.
Okay, we're fine.
We're so fine.
Everything is okay.
SPIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIINNNNNN!
I think everything is okay.
I can tell.
There's so many bodies in front of me.
I can't tell anymore.
He's playing with yellow.
Thanks, guys.
Okay.
Alright, he's fine.
Tau Tau is so healthy right now.
Me, I'm not so much.
Not so much, I would admit.
Spit!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
Okay, we gotta use this.
Keep... Don't worry, he's so alive!
He's so alive!
I think he's fine.
I think he'll be fine.
I can see how alive he is somewhere in this area.
Like, I'm pretty sure he's very alive.
He's somewhere there.
Like, I might not know where he is, but I am pretty sure he's okay.
He's so healthy!
He's somewhere here, and I believe he's incredibly healthy somewhere.
Like, I was like, Doki, protect him!
And I'm like, I think he's okay?
I think so?
Alright, am I doing anything?
Okay, Guan Yu might actually die, though.
Okay, we can get rid of this one chariot.
Alright, are they all dead?
Please tell me I have killed them all!
Alright, nice.
Okay, we did it.
Alright, let's help the reds.
Alright, we gotta go help the red.
Real quick.
Don't worry, I got them.
I believe.
Don't worry, reds!
It's my turn to help you!
They're so healthy!
See, I told you they're so healthy.
Let's help the child.
See, I told you.
Look at that.
Where did he go?
Sometimes I just don't know where they are.
Alright, encourage!
And then charge!
Do everything!
Dragons, everything!
Don't let him touch the ground!
Alright, nice.
See, I told you they're fine.
Spin!
Nice, we need that.
We need that.
Am I doing anything?
Oh, there we go.
Look at that.
Don't worry, child.
Boom!
Goodbye!
Nice.
Oh my god, we're actually getting buns.
Magic!
Nice.
Assault!
There we go.
Is that it?
Is there anymore?
Oh no, there is.
Get over here.
Get over here!
You think men can protect you?
Oh my god, get in this corner!
That's fucking right.
That's right, stay in the corner!
I won't let you leave!
Alright, goodbye.
Nice.
Spin!
The corner of shame.
Wait, where did he go?
He left the corner.
Where did he go?
Who let him out of the corner?
Get over here.
I refuse to ever let you leave this corner.
That's right, you live here now.
And now you live here in the corner.
That's fucking right.
Get back in there!
The prisoner of the corner.
Get your ass back in here!
Alright, we did it.
Yay!
Alright, you're welcome guys.
The prisoner here of the corner.
Alright, we go this way.
I don't wanna climb up, so I'm gonna go through the door.
I'm just like, alright, you guys got that.
I'm not climbing up there.
Absol, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When you wanted tactics but Lupe gave you TikTok.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, we're almost there.
Alright, give me more generals to kill.
I need to level up.
Oh shit, okay.
Now I can do it.
Easy.
Alright, I'm going in.
I'm going straight in.
Alright, I'm not going straight in.
Alright, we'll deal with that later.
Let me kill the small guys first.
I don't know.
It seems a little hard over there.
Seems a little difficult.
I'll get rid of the other mini guys first.
I'm ready.
No, I'm ready.
Let's go!
For Doki!
Okay, um...
Guys, can they charge?
Alright, that was...
That was a little anti-climatic.
Because I thought, you know...
I legitimately thought that, you know, they'd do more.
But that's okay.
I thought they would break down barriers.
Like, that's alright.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Don't worry, we got it.
We can both spin.
Break.
Reduce Yuen Shu's health by 15%.
Wait, where is he?
Wait, oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute!
Wait a minute!
Wait a minute, where is he at?
Where is he?
Okay, we're not gonna make it.
Bro, okay.
Bro, how am I...
How do I make it to him?!
He's so...
Like, I'm trying to fucking get to him right now!
I am trying so hard to get to this guy!
Oh my god.
Okay, guys, I don't know about that.
He is actually trying to run away.
Oh, no.
Oh, we did it!
Seven seconds!
Alright.
That's fine.
I use the power of Guanyin.
Nine...
A thousand?!
I did it!
That's actually crazy.
Wait, where is he running to?
Yuan Shu, where are you running to?
Yuan Shu, I'm like right here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
It's okay.
We're fine.
I literally just need to get power up.
Everything will be fine.
Okay, um...
Oh, shit!
Um...
We gotta run.
We gotta get...
Okay, bun.
Bun time.
I'll be back.
I'll be...
Don't worry.
I just gotta restock on some buns.
I'll be back.
I'll be...
Where are the buns?
I'll be back.
Wait, there are buns there?
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry, I'll be okay.
Oh, there's some buns.
There's some buns.
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
Round two.
Snack break's over.
Guys, snack break is over.
I'm back.
I'm done with snacky break.
Nice.
Guys, I did it.
Sorry, I had to have a snack break.
But it's okay.
I'm okay now.
Alright, I'm back.
Again?!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, charge through!
I didn't get the USU!
Charge!
I didn't get them!
Okay.
We should be close.
Please, he's running away like a fucking coward!
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I did it.
Please, please.
I have so much to deal with.
Please, he keeps running away!
I don't like it!
He keeps running away.
I'm trying my best!
I'm trying!
He keeps running away!
I have to!
Okay.
It's fine.
He's looking for butts.
He's also looking for butts.
Alright, nice.
Jesus, fucking finally.
Oh my god.
He didn't even finish his dialogue.
I'm done.
Yay!
Yippee!
Well, time to chop off his hands.
We did it, guys!
Okay.
Got the blade.
Yippee!
Level up!
Okay, plus 93.
What did I get from that?
Yeah, I swear to god I have not been leveling up any of these.
I don't know.
I don't want to woo any of these people.
I already paid the win enough.
Alright, nice.
We got a ring of light.
And then we can get increased health.
And we can get attack later.
Hello, guys.
Welcome back.
What are you flying?
An actual strategist?
Okay.
Yes, they are.
You are whipped as fuck, Lupe.
And Lord Luibu's skill in battle is unmatched.
No talent of mine raises me up above my rivals.
What talent?
It's hard to admit.
You just talk.
You're just a politician.
You talk and do nothing.
What fucking talent?
I'm only following you for one person.
If anything, the majority of people will die before they even come close to finding that for themselves.
Being born into this turbulent world, clinging to a dream, and seeing it through is a privilege only granted to a lucky few.
Yes, that is certainly true.
But what do you intend to do in such a world?
I...
Are we really letting him lead us?
I will create a world where people can live as they wish.
Oh, no.
A world where no one will be forced to serve the will of another.
Where all people can choose a path and follow it to a future of their own making.
But I am still powerless.
For now, I will be forced to remain under Lord Cao Cao's control.
Would you still be willing to wait with me?
To stand by until it is our time to rise?
Of course.
How could I oppose this grand pledge you have shown for us?
I believe in you, brother.
I will never leave your side.
As much as I'd like to crush Lui Bu and the others right now, you've convinced me.
The wait is worth it.
I'll wait with you, too.
Thank you.
It will be hard, but I know we can do it.
No matter what anyone says, I'll stay true to myself.
I will do what I believe is right.
Lui Bu Terry.
Thank you for the super chat, Ajo.
Thank you, thank you.
This stone on the road is about to roll its way to victory.
Yeah, victory.
That's what I'm gonna hear from Juca then.
God.
If the greatest strategy was not on your side, I'd be peacing out by now.
I'd be fucking gone.
Alright.
What letters do I have?
Ooh!
How do I proclaim that our kingdom is under attack?
All those who will fill the fight must make haste.
Okay, that was just nothing.
Alright.
Are there any other weapons though?
It's just a spear.
I wish they have the...
I really wanna use the hoops.
Alright, Guan Yin.
Whoops.
What do you wanna talk about?
I was serious when I said I'd wait.
But I don't think I can stomach Lui Bu for much longer.
He is a beast by nature.
He will run wild as he pleases.
The way he wields his power to consume all in his path reminds me of Dan Shua.
He isn't that bad, guys.
Like, he treats me okay.
What?
So you're saying you see something good in that brute?
I mean, he bought me dinner.
You've never been on good terms with Lui Bu.
Even I have nothing to say in his defense.
Nonetheless, as long as our brother hasn't lost his will to fight, I will always be right behind him.
But he treats me okay!
Even Zhang Fei is starting to lose heart.
How much longer can we expect the others to hold on?
Everyone, please make haste to the war room!
What's all the excitement about?
Lui Bu's forces.
Again?
What?
How are they invading?
We just got out of a war!
Oh my God, there's another fucking battle.
I request your help from all over in far too many tasks rooting me in place, which is where you come in.
Alright.
I'll show Lord Liu Bei what I'm made of.
Alright guys, before I do this, I'm gonna go microwave some food because I haven't had lunch yet.
And it's 5pm.
I'll be right back.
I'm just gonna microwave food real quick.
Alright.
I got my food.
I microwaved some food.
Some rice and meat.
Okay.
Goddamnit, I wish there was a war so I could just eat while we listen to some fucking Riz.
I thought I had more Riz to go through.
Alright, maybe I do.
Give me a sec.
Alright, let's see if we can find anybody to talk to.
There has to be some guy that wants to talk to me.
While I'm trying to eat.
There has to be somebody.
Alright.
Let's go home and see if there's anybody that wants to talk to me.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Interaction.
Goddamnit, why does no one want to talk to me?
Please!
How else am I gonna fucking eat?
I need somebody to talk to me.
Okay.
Where do I acquire this?
Alright, let's find this little shit.
And then like...
Then we have a cutscene.
And I can eat.
I forgot what I was doing.
I forgot where this little thing is.
Okay, it's in the Yang province.
Alright, let's find Yang province.
Where the fuck is Yang?
Wait, is there no bottom right here?
Is this all Yang?
Wait, do I not...
Have I not unlocked any area there?
Did I forgot to unlock anything?
Oh my god, I did.
Are there no markers anywhere for this area?
Oh, that's bad.
Wait, there's no markers here.
There has to be a single fucking marker here somewhere.
I'm still in Yang, right?
Oh my god, this is a huge territory.
There has to be one marker here.
Like, one.
That's alright, there's a lot of coins.
Nice.
Where the fuck is my grass?
Oh my god, there's no grass anywhere.
Oh, there it is, there's a marker.
Okay, there you go.
There's still a...
There you go, that's what we needed.
Alright, and then we unlock here.
Oh my god, we finally found it.
It's been like 20 years and we finally found it.
Alright, time to talk to my doctor so I can eat.
Doctor, doctor.
I have the last incense.
Alright.
Alright, time to go to the village.
Light that shit up.
And I can eat now.
Oh shit, I'm surrounded.
I swear to god, this is like a fucking one minute cutscene.
I swear to god.
Shit.
An informant.
Perhaps someone who disagreed with the position you took.
Now listen.
I am the strongest fighter in this village.
And you two will only get in my way.
Do not try to follow me.
You have to live, Silouan.
Live, and create the world we dreamed of.
Chua, wait!
Foolish girl.
Silouan, after her.
I cannot fly with only one of my wings.
We have to save her.
Chua entrusted you with her dream.
She knew she would never be able to realize that dream.
Yet she believed you would make it come to pass.
Perhaps my father believed something similar.
But Chua survived, and she appeared before you.
Does that mean...
No.
He couldn't.
Things are drawing to a close, Silouan.
And I will be at your side until the end.
That's it?
What the fuck?
I tried it.
I barely ate.
That's it?
Alright, I'm fighting one more.
No!
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
I risked too much.
I risked too much and there's nothing left to risk.
No!
There's nothing left to risk.
I did too much.
Goddammit.
Alright.
You guys read for me while I finish eating.
No!
Goddamn!
I risked too much!
Alright, nice.
Cut scenes.
It is difficult to believe that Lord Cao Cao would be so careless.
I suspect he intentionally allowed the enemy to intercept the letter.
Still, it's not like we wrote back accepting Cao Cao's proposal.
Chengu must be trying to get ahead of things.
But that doesn't make attacking an ally before trying to negotiate any less dishonorable.
This must be Lord Lu Bu's answer.
In the world he wants to create, there is no honor or compassion.
It is a world of beasts, where the strong simply devour the weak.
It is totally incompatible with everything I want to achieve.
The time has come for us to break free from Lu Bu.
But our forces alone do not stand a chance against him.
What will we do, brother?
We will abandon Xiao Pei and join forces with Cao Cao's army.
Lu Bu will be no match for us together.
I'm sure you each have your misgivings about Lord Cao Cao.
But for now, think of him as a means to an end.
Yeah, I was on board from the start.
As long as we get to crush Lu Bu, you won't hear me complaining.
No matter who offers us help or favors, it will never come at the cost of my soul.
I will subdue and consume all who would look down upon us.
Neither strength nor reason will bring an end to the chaos.
And it's up to us to prove it to the world.
Shall we start?
I'd say so.
Aye.
I hate it.
It's a sacrifice I make for Dynasty Warriors.
Hmm.
You were too fast to read?
That's okay.
I don't need to read for his strategies.
Lu Bei is literally just Ongabunga.
Like, what strategy?
You really need to know the War Council when everything is just head straight there and then see if it works.
Like, he has not changed his strategy once.
Like, I don't need to reread it.
It's the same thing.
He's literally like, charge ahead.
I'm like, okay.
I don't need a... I don't need strategy for that.
I just lost him.
Alright.
Let's go!
Alright, here we go.
Get in battle.
Alright, hide my meal.
I'm full now.
Where am I?
Spin!
What the fuck were you trying to do?
Like...
Were you trying to do your own spin?
Do you know who I am?
That's right.
No spinning for you.
Get out of here.
Alright, let's get over here.
Wait, where is he?
Wait, where is Lupe?
I don't even... Wait, okay.
Where is he anyway?
Oh, he's all the way down here.
Okay, I was clearly not paying attention.
Alright, maybe I should have paid attention to the War Council.
Nah, he'll be fine.
Lupe should be fine, right?
He'll be fine.
Okay.
Okay, don't worry.
I can just... Wait.
He doesn't need me?
I can't even go there.
Yeah, I was gonna say, it's blocked.
Spin!
Oh my god, he can just run away from my spin like that?
Okay.
Don't worry.
He'll be fine.
I still own this area.
I still own this base.
It'll be fine.
Okay, don't worry.
Everything is okay.
I still own this house.
Get out!
That's right!
Get out of my house!
That is so easy.
Oh shit, okay, we gotta...
Wait, what do I... Okay, do I need to help him?
Nah, he'll be fine.
I need to save my sworn brothers who stayed behind to keep the enemy at bay.
Then you keep going.
We'll take care of rescuing your brothers.
They'll be fine.
I believe in them.
Then I will do as you say.
I'm counting on you.
Alright, I'm here now.
Hello!
Don't worry, I can take them all down.
I literally killed three armies today.
What's another army to me?
Alright.
Why do you still have two eyes?
Why has no one shot you in the eye yet?
Why are you still not that sexy?
Wait, no, he does have one eye.
Wait, wait, no, when did he shoot... Wait, no, he has one eye.
Wait a minute, and I wasn't there?!
They shot your eye and I wasn't there?!
I can't believe it!
I'm so sad.
Right before... Oh, I can't believe it.
He didn't invite me.
He didn't invite me to watch him eat his own eye.
I'm so sad.
What's the point?
Like, what's the point if I can't even be there?
Nice, goodbye.
Wait, who's they?
Who's that guy?
He just came out of nowhere.
Alright, let's duel.
I'm ready.
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh wait, actually I should use this one.
Let me swap to my other weapon first, but then I realized...
Like, I have to use this one because it's just so much stronger.
Alright, get over here.
I need to win one more duel.
Okay.
Almost done.
Get over here.
That's right.
And you lose the duel.
Not even one hit.
I completed his training.
Look at that.
I'm here to kill Lu Bu and I completed his training.
Killed two birds with one stone.
It's the dragoon's destiny, exactly.
Really?
How are you scared, Lu Bu?
I've been...
This is not my first war.
This is not my first war that you poorly planned.
And yet I've somehow reigned supreme in every poorly planned fight you got me into.
Where is Guan Yun?
I thought he was going to be with me.
Let's move on.
Time to act.
Okay,
one last hit.
One last hit.
He's one hit.
Get over here.
Nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Wait, who's over there?
Is that...
The party's already started.
Wait, is that Lu Bei down there?
Lu Bei, what the fuck are you doing?
Follow them.
Lu Bei, what the fuck?
Oh wait, that's Xiao Hu Dan.
Okay, nevermind.
I don't care.
That's okay.
You didn't... He didn't invite me to the eye eating, so I don't care anymore.
I don't care.
I don't care about him anymore.
He didn't invite me to an important day of his life.
So, who cares?
Who cares about him?
Alright, let's get rid of these guys.
I feel so betrayed.
It was a pivotal part of his life and I wasn't even invited.
Like, what's the point?
Did I kill him?
Oh, I did.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
They're all dead?
Nice.
Now we can break through.
Let's move.
Quickly.
Alright.
I'll go to Zhang Fei and Lu Bei.
Oh wait, I...
Oh, I created... I ditched the brothers and made them run with the others.
You know what?
I believe in Guan Yun and Zhang Fei.
That's fine.
No, it's okay.
We did it.
We'll leave them...
Oh, goddammit.
Are we really?
Do we have to... Oh my god.
We have to... Okay, I guess I'll go back.
That's fine.
I'll open the door.
I'll go from behind.
Open the door.
Don't worry, I'll go from behind.
It's okay.
They won't expect it.
Wait, what?
Bro, what?
What do you mean?
Lu Bei's not even here.
It's just me.
Alright, I've opened the back doors.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay, um...
This might've been a bad idea.
Going from the back.
Guys.
I don't...
It might've been a bad idea.
I'm not sure yet.
We'll see.
We'll see from here.
We'll see from here if he lives.
Alright, it's fine.
I just need to claim this base and then everything will be fine.
They're not that strong.
They're not that strong, I believe.
I think I can get him.
They're not that strong.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
I'm almost there.
Last one.
There you go.
See?
We got it.
We can save him.
It's fine.
Open the door.
I'm coming over.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
It's saveable.
See?
Look at that.
Oh, look at that.
Wait, who?
Who?
Who just challenged me?
What the fuck?
Who challenged... Bro, you're one hit.
Get out.
You literally won it.
Okay, Guan Yin is fine.
Look, he's okay.
He's okay.
Okay, I saved him.
See?
Look at that.
Everything is fine.
Save what?
Yeah, they're winning.
Look at that.
They were winning.
He didn't need saving.
Look at that.
He's so healthy.
Okay.
Oh, you're not that... You're not that strong anymore.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
See?
Look at that.
Not that scared.
Boop.
Did I hit him?
Oh, I did.
Nice.
Alright.
You're 1 HP, little guy.
You know what that means?
Goodbye.
See?
It's that easy.
I told you guys I can do it.
We found the back door.
Justkida, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She's Xiaohu's gunwoman.
I'm stealing from chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Zero, only the pretty man ventured the back door.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where is everybody?
Alright, they're like 1 HP now.
Goodbye.
Spin!
Easy.
Alright, go to the bay!
I created a path!
Now go!
I went from the back door!
Here we go.
We did it, guys.
Now to chop off his head.
I'm ready.
We're all waiting for you.
Alright.
Let's go escape, guys.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Excuse me?
There's more?
What the fuck is he gonna do?
He's just a nerd.
Bro, he doesn't even fight.
He's just a fucking nerd.
Are we really gonna let a nerd get us?
Where is he?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
This nerd is fighting back.
What the fuck?
He's fighting back.
Alright, let's get him.
Get him.
Get over here.
What the fuck is his... Okay, not gonna lie, but what the fuck is his sound balance?
Why is it so loud?
Why is Chen Gong's sound balancing so loud when you hit him?
You guys hear that, right?
He's like...
What the fuck?
I can hear everything.
Alright, he has one more armor left.
Get over here.
Leave!
Guys,
I think we got way into it.
More into it than I expected.
So that I may be true to myself.
I guess it's about time.
And we will follow you.
Wherever that may lead.
Food reward.
Nice.
New skill.
Oh my god, Birch is going to be level 20 soon.
My little guy.
My big boy is going to grow up big and strong.
Okay, let's get this.
And what's this?
What's the money?
Okay, I don't need more items.
I'm not even using items at all.
I'm ungodbunga.
No items.
Found destination.
Lord Xiaohou Yuan, thank you for your help.
See, I told you he's hotter than an iPad.
It's just sad that we didn't get to see it.
Hello there.
Have I ever fallen so low?
Perhaps not.
But without that fall, we never would have found the courage to rise to even greater heights.
Guan Yu, Zhang Fei, thank you for believing in me, even at my worst.
I have you to thank as well.
I could not have made it this far without all of you.
You've changed, brother.
Have I?
Yes.
You look like a man of purpose now.
Yeah, you were looking pretty pathetic before.
Guys, I can't believe you're calling Xiaohu Deng Chinese Snake when Xiaohu Deng has been part of history for like hundreds of years.
Xiaohu Deng was there first.
He's a real person.
He's an actual real person.
You're like Chinese Snake.
That's crazy.
He's been around for thousands of years.
An original big boss.
You find yourself a little bit too good with your hands to be a mere warrior?
And how definitely you handle gems.
The speed of your work is remarkable as well.
It's like you can see exactly what needs to be extracted.
That's how it appears anyway.
By the way, a local boy came by to thank you.
He said you carved him as a wooden horse out of a log with a small knife.
And apparently, thanks to that, he was finally able to get other children to accept him as a playmate.
That's all it takes?
A fucking horse?
He also mentioned that when he first saw you, he was too frightened to move, since you suddenly pulled out a knife while staring into the distance by the riverbank.
What were you thinking?
I suppose it did work out in the end though.
He just pulled out a fucking knife in front of a child?
What were you thinking?
I mean, he's right though.
The fuck, who did you pull out a knife in front of a child?
Alright, I'm gonna do the Lupe request.
There you go.
I increased our Lupe bond.
Sorry, I'm eating.
Hehehe.
Open the door!
What do you mean the attempt failed?
Like, did you- Why didn't you guys give up?
Just open- open the door.
Open the door, Dragoons.
There's no re- it's just like three guys.
Like, why are you scared?
We got it.
You're just like, owie!
It's three guys, Dragoons.
There's 15- I have 15 of you!
And you're scared of three guys?
Alright,
let's get rid of him.
Magic!
There you go.
There you go, we did it.
We used magic.
They're scary!
They touched me!
Look, I didn't- they're like, I didn't sign up to get hit.
I signed up to- to block doors!
Alright.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on!
You're so low!
Let me kill you!
Oh my god.
How tanky are you?
Just let me kill you!
Alright, I did it.
It worked.
Alright, the peasant should be okay now.
Now run!
Leave!
Get up!
I will push you- I'm pushing him over.
Oh my god.
Just get up!
There we go.
Now leave.
He's surrounded.
Alright, nice.
I'm a hero.
I'm a hero, guys.
Yay!
Puppies!
Alright, Lube, I did your stuff.
Yay, old coins!
After I'm lucky enough to have you help me along the way, I'm truly blessed.
It's people like you that enable me to walk this path I've chosen, and that's the truth to it.
Again, I thank you.
Alright, goodbye.
Level 38.
Okay, we're not gonna do this for now.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure I have everything I need.
I don't know how to do this.
I don't know how- I don't know how to do this correctly.
I'm, like, struggling so hard.
Alright, let's kill Lu Bu!
Again, for the third time.
But this is the last time we finally kill Lu Bu.
Alright, what do I have to do?
Lu Bu is currently in this castle.
Okay.
We now- Oh wait, is this where we flood the castle?
Right?
Is that the- Is that the infamous mission where you flood the castle?
I don't remember.
There's so many famous ones.
Yeah, the flood attack, right?
Yeah!
It's where we flood the castle!
Okay.
Okay, so I just have to destroy that.
Yeah!
Okay.
Where's east?
Okay, here.
We're happy to help you.
Alright, let's go flood the castle, guys!
They can't swim.
Lu Bu has never- Lu Bu has never swam before.
Oh wait, did my mic volume change?
Oh shit, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I went too loud.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry to everybody's ears.
That's my bad.
Whoops.
We cannot- Yeah, I accidentally went too loud.
You must fall here at Xiaoping no matter what it takes.
Alright, get out of here!
You're never gonna be with me, Zhang Fei!
You literally lost the castle!
Alright.
Lu Bu, just give- Zhang Fei, just give up.
I'm ready.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm almost there.
I mean, yeah.
What do you mean?
He's like, how dare you fucking try to make- What the fuck?!
He summoned his own!
He can do tornadoes too?!
I'm saying- I mean like, yeah, of course.
Why the fuck would you be at a disadvantage in war?
Yeah, he's definitely not a number guy.
He's worse than- He's worse than Lu Fei when it comes to strategy.
Woo!
Oh my god.
The worst thing about the tornado is just the fact that sometimes they're just everywhere.
I'm like, where do I go?
Oof.
Alright, we're almost there.
Or...
No, stop thinking!
Stop thinking!
No!
I don't know what you're talking about!
We're not going to any flood area?
What do you mean?
Who said that?
Alright.
Yeah, only cowards and nerds strategize.
Exactly.
They use their brains because they have no strength.
Alright, nice.
All I'm saying- Oh shit, Lu Bu's coming over.
Oh shit!
Oh shit, he's coming over!
Oh, we're preparing our flood attacks?
Wait, who's that?
Who said that?
Wait, where is he?
Li Dian.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, no, he's dead.
I was like, no, he's dead.
I'm not coming back.
I have good luck.
You're way too far.
There's no way to save you.
So this is what a true warrior looks like.
I must find a way to overcome this situation.
Good luck.
Sorry, you're on the other side.
You were not meant to win that war.
What?
Lord Lu Bu has left the castle?
I suppose it was foolish to think we could control him.
Why would you ever use Lu Bu as a puppet?
Like, that's just dumb.
Why?
Lu Bu is like the last person you want to use as a puppet.
He does not give a fuck.
Jesus Christ, where is that fucking title?
Alright.
We're almost done with this one too.
We're almost there!
He can't swim!
Swim!
Don't worry!
Lu Bu didn't learn how to swim!
We can do this!
How many betrayals?
Three?
Four?
I lost count.
I'm heading over.
I like how the shield guy is just watching this guy being flipped around.
He's like, do you think he's okay?
Do you think he needs us to move any closer?
Nice.
Goodbye.
Oh, he's not dead yet.
Goodbye for real.
Oh, okay.
I did it.
They all just fucking collapsed.
I take those.
Alright, last guy.
Get over here.
But it's always- But it's worked?
Oh, every time!
Why do I stop when it keeps working?
Alright, nice.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Alright, finish all the dams.
Is that everything?
Yeah, I did it.
That should be everything.
Alright, where is he?
Okay, he's over there.
Okay, we're fine.
Is that all the dams?
He's not okay.
It's fine.
We don't care.
He might not be okay, but it's okay.
Wait, what?
Alright, that's the last floodgate.
Is that another floodgate?
I can't tell.
Is this also a floodgate?
There's so many.
Wow, what am I gonna do?
Wait, what?
I kinda fucking hate it.
Okay.
You know what?
I like the effort.
10 out of 10 formation.
10 out of 10.
How did he break through our walls?
How did he do that?
Alright, we did it.
Alright, how do I start it?
Where's the tower?
Wait.
Oh, that's the tower.
Okay, I did not know where the tower was.
Alright, don't worry.
We got the tower.
Alright.
Don't worry.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I can rebuild this.
The greatest strategy ever.
Just walk around.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I was like, alright, so like...
Like...
What kind of fucking...
What was that fucking shield?
I was so confused.
Like, what did he want me to do there?
Not walk around?
Okay.
Okay, where's the guy?
I've like lost track of him.
Where is he?
Oh, okay.
I shot behind me.
That's awkward.
It's okay.
There should be enough for Guanyin though.
He's one hit.
Nice!
It's the water time!
Open the dam!
Nobody's gonna hit you!
Nice.
Come on!
We're almost there.
Activate!
Okay.
We did it, guys.
Now they can't swim.
They never learn how to swim.
That's right.
His one weakness...
Water!
What?
What are you gonna do now?!
That's right!
His greatest weakness!
Liquid!
Alright, we gotta kill this guy though.
I wasn't expecting defectors.
We need to rethink our next move.
There must be a way.
Dracos, get ready!
Too bad, too worse.
No, this ends it.
Time to act.
My blade and my will have not been broken yet!
Woah, now!
I must get back to the castle.
Alright, you should say that before I started like, you know...
Making you...
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Oh, wait, he wants to duel?
Let's fucking go!
I get to waste less time!
Let's go!
Okay, um...
Um, okay...
Oh, ho, ho, ho, okay!
Um...
Is that...
Okay, he...
Okay, he is...
He is a lot stronger, guys.
Um...
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
I made it back, I made it back, I made it back, guys.
It's fine.
There you go, I got it back, I got it back.
I got that word, not gonna lie.
But it's okay.
Oh, shit.
I got that word, but it's okay.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, this guy actually knows how to duel.
He has hands!
But I did it.
I did it.
Alright, nice.
Um...
I don't know!
Wait, he has peers?
Wait, he came back?
I'm coming in!
Hope he didn't have a move...
i'm just gonna knock the enemy and corner him.
Alright.
The FIET CHANG-HAWN, alright cool.
I can do that.
Jesus Chris, what the fuck?!
OMG!
Bro, I can just do that.
WOOOO!
I'm MOWING the line!
I'm gonna MOW that line!
Okay.
Goodbye.
Tenacity?
I just killed a guy.
How do you still have tenacity?
What the fuck?
Don't worry, I can keep mowing this lawn.
Let me just keep mowing.
Wow, I already killed 200 within that time frame.
Don't worry, I can do it again!
I need more people to mow.
Okay, where am I?
I lost track of where I am.
Jesus Christ, I still need to kill 700 more?!
Alright, fuck this.
Okay, a thousand.
Army of one!
Alright, 200 more!
Who wants to have winnows tonight?
Alright, I can.
You guys know that.
Maybe it'd be easier if I sent out the tornado.
Maybe it would be.
Yeah, it was.
It was actually easier by sending out a tornado.
Oh my god, please.
The guard has fled!
Who left?
All of you guys left?!
Okay, all my dragoons left, guys.
I'm literally mowing the lawn for you guys and you still leave?!
It's fine, I did it.
I didn't need you guys.
I literally mowed the lawn and you all left.
I can't believe it.
Chat, I can't believe it.
What are you afraid of?!
Every dragoon for themselves.
I killed them all!
They're all dead!
What more are you running from?!
Wait, I literally killed them all.
We can't touch grass.
Like, is there more?
Wait, they're all dead.
Yeah!
Wait, where?!
There's like, remaining forces somewhere, but where?!
Alright, we just go in.
We just go straight in.
Oh, there they are.
There he is.
I was like, where the fuck is the last remaining guards or forces?
Okay, nice.
Get out of here.
Hello?
Tau Tau?
Army of One here?
What?
Army of One?!
That's fine.
That's okay.
Like, I guess I don't matter.
Where is he?
Alright, get over here.
Alright, yoink my credit now.
Alright, here we go.
I summoned Guan Yu just to kill him.
Get over here.
What did I do?
That's fucking right.
It's Musou time.
That's right.
Oh, I have- I can do expand energy dome?!
What the fuck?
I went JJK over there.
Get in my domain expansion.
Take this!
I literally do a main expansion in there.
Goodbye.
It looked so cool.
Another victory in the name of my brother.
After exhausting all my cunning, here I am.
Yippee!
Guys, I think Chen Gong is very mad at Lu Bu, guys.
Whoa.
Nice.
Yippee!
Alright, time to fight Lu Bu for the fifth time.
I'm so ready.
Oh, here we go.
Alright, guys.
Oh, you're all gonna watch?
You're not gonna help out?
Yeah?
Hey, guys.
You wanna come in here with me?
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my- Oh, my god.
I forgot.
I- I forgot.
Okay.
I forgot how much I hated this.
It doesn't even get off his fucking horse.
Oh, my- Get off your horse!
Oh, my god.
This guy- Please.
Not fair!
He just- He can just do that?
He can just
- Like, he just runs away on his horse!
I'm trying!
Oh, my god!
Oh, my god.
He got off his horse, guys.
Guys, he did it.
Oh, my god.
He did it.
He got off his horse, guys.
Oh, my god.
The bare minimum.
At least it- Guys, he did his bare minimum.
Jesus Christ!
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god!
Please.
Please, I don't know if I have enough funds.
Oh, my god.
I'm on- Oh, my god.
Oh, my god, you fucking- What do you mean you fled?!
I have two buns left.
I have two buns and he's not even close!
Like- Yes.
Bro, I'm not even halfway!
Oh, my god.
Jeez!
Oh, my god!
Please tell me there's buns near me.
Please tell me there's buns near me, guys.
Oh, there is.
I see it.
I see the buns.
Okay.
I'm only not even halfway.
I think that's the worst part.
Jesus Christ!
Goodbye.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have to do this first.
All right, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Go to the buns.
It's just me, Guan Yun, and Zhang Fei.
My dragon- I- I swear to god, dragons!
You guys will help!
You guys are gonna stay throughout the fight, right?
Right?
Right, guys?
You'll stay throughout it, right, guys?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
It's fine.
Okay.
Oh my god, we're halfway.
We're halfway.
Guys, we've hit halfway.
We've hit halfway, guys.
I have no buns.
I have no more buns.
Is there any more buns near me?
Is there?
Yes!
There's one more!
Guys, what?!
Dragons, what do you mean you're falling back?!
Dragons, what do you mean?!
What do you mean, guys?
What do you mean?
What happened to helping me?
Dragons, come on!
What happened to Fordoki?!
Guys!
Come on, we're almost there!
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's just me and Guanyin, but I don't think Guanyin's gonna be here any longer, guys.
Guys, I don't- I think he's gonna leave very soon.
Oh my god, are you only doing that little damage?
It's literally just me and him!
Wait, he fucking- oh my god!
He actually stunned it too!
Oh my god.
It's just me and him!
It's actually just me and him!
Oh my god, he counters my counter!
Okay.
Guys, is there any more buns?
Guys, there's no more buns!
Guys, there's no more buns, guys!
I'm so scared!
There's no more buns!
Oh my god.
Stop countering!
Oh my god!
Jesus.
Oh no.
Guys, I think it's over.
Guys, I think it's over, guys.
Guys, it might be over!
It might be over!
I have no more buns!
There's no more, guys!
There's actually no more buns!
No!
I dodged everything!
It was so close!
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh my god!
Actually, where did I come from?
What do you mean, where am I looking?
I don't even know where...
I didn't see him!
He can't be!
What do you want from me?
He actually can't be!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, we have one bun.
No bun in a dream.
Oh my god, okay.
But we literally almost did it.
We almost...
We almost one-tried him.
That's crazy though.
Okay, I'm gonna admit, I am proud of us for almost getting a one-try.
First try.
Jesus Christ.
Whoops.
Okay.
What?
He countered me!
Oh god.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, I'm not winning this one.
I'm literally one HP, guys.
Yes, I'm one HP, guys.
Oh no!
He countered my counter!
I literally have no more buns left.
Jesus.
So illegal.
So...
Like, he camps me out of it too.
Okay.
I'm locking in, guys.
I'm locking in.
Okay.
I have to lock in.
Oh my god.
Lock in.
Oh shit!
Almost got it too!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no!
Oh my god, I said no!
Okay.
That was an accident.
Does he counter?
He counters my counter!
It's like not fair!
Oh.
Is this the only thing I can do?
No way!
What?!
I got hit?!
Oh my god.
I can't believe I got hit.
Wait, I'm focusing.
Okay.
Focus.
Jesus Christ!
Alright.
Your turn.
Boom!
Alright, I can whale him a little bit apparently.
Okay.
Jesus.
Oh my god, that's bullshit!
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on!
He's so strong!
That's okay, that's okay, that's okay, that's okay!
Goodbye!
Oh!
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Sometimes I'm like, where is he?
He has to get close.
He has to- Nice.
Come on.
He's so close.
Oh.
Oh!
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Please, please, please, please hit him!
No!
It
was so close!
Where is he?
It was so close.
I'm so sad.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
He's so strong!
Jesus Christ!
Come on!
Oh my god.
I want to get away from him.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I'm locked in, I'm locked in, I'm locked in.
Get closer.
Jesus Christ!
Oh.
Okay.
Come on, come on.
I'm locking in right now.
What?!
Okay, that was a dodge.
That was 100% a dodge right there.
Oh my god, I wish there were more buttons.
Oh no!
Why is there no more buttons?!
Please!
Okay, maybe I'm not locked in, guys.
Maybe I was not locked in.
Maybe I was not locked in, guys.
Can you really blame me?
I have to fight Lupo.
Oh my god.
Can you really blame me?
I have to fight this fucker!
Wait, do I have any items?
Oh my god, wait.
I think I have extra items.
Wait, I'm so dumb.
This last minute, no item run.
Wait a minute.
I should have...
Wait, where are my items?
Oh my god, I didn't equip any.
I didn't equip any.
I'm so...
Oh no.
Nevermind, guys.
Okay, we gotta redo this.
We're redoing this.
I'm redoing this.
I'm already like...
Just kill me.
Reset this.
Restart this.
Real gamers don't use items.
Damn you, Pastuki!
Why?
Why didn't you have any items?
Okay.
I'm gonna go silent mode.
I have to try.
Okay.
Go focus.
Okay!
We all know that was bullshit.
That was so bullshit.
That was actually so bullshit.
That was...
Oh my god.
I perfect evaded that and it counted as a hit.
Alright.
Oh.
Come on.
Alright.
I don't feel like I got this anymore.
Lock in.
I hate you.
I hate you so much!
Damn.
Take that!
Ready up!
You're finished!
Time to act.
Be
proud of your strength, but there are so few who can fare this well against me.
Now I shall allow you to bear witness to the entirety of my might.
You're finished.
Ready yourself.
Looking rough.
I need to use that as like...
Okay.
I need to use it as like a defense.
Gotta be quicker.
Oh.
Alright.
What's he doing?
What is he doing?
I'm
so confused!
I'm so sad.
I hate this guy so much.
I didn't know!
You're finished.
This guy sucks.
I'm like Dark Soulings right now.
I have the Dark Souls in my Dynasty Warriors game.
Take that!
This is not fair.
With all my might.
I don't...
What is this fight?
What the fuck is this fight?
Okay, end me.
I'm finished.
This is like the worst save point I have.
That's actually the worst save point it gave me.
I hate this.
I hate this save point.
Alright.
I can't.
It's always a different one the entire time.
It's always a different save point.
That's the worst part.
Okay, full focus.
Jesus Christ.
I feel so finished.
With all my might.
Full focus.
I need to dodge it when he's at...
Christ, whenever he does that, it's so scary.
Take that.
Jesus.
Okay.
You're finished.
Time to attack.
Ready yourself.
Jesus Christ.
Really?
Time to attack.
Okay.
Oh my god.
The counter.
The counter shit is actually... Oh my god.
It's actually...
Oh my god.
That's it.
I'm...
I'm using a different weapon.
I'm using this.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh my god.
What?
My rage.
Okay.
Maybe not this weapon.
I'm not used to it.
Maybe... Okay.
I'm resetting.
I wasn't ready guys.
I wasn't ready.
I wasn't...
Jesus.
I hate that.
I hate...
Oh shit.
Okay.
I keep forgetting that I'm not on the right weapons right now.
Alright.
Okay.
Nice.
Come on.
Okay.
Concentrate.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, when he does his own thing.
Like, I don't know.
No.
No!
Okay.
I think...
Okay, I think...
I don't know.
Actually, I don't know.
I don't...
What?
I don't know.
I can't think.
I don't know anymore.
I don't know.
I don't think... I don't think anymore.
Oh my god, I can parry his parry?!
Wait, what?!
Okay, now I know!
Okay, I can parry his parry.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Okay, at least now I know.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just keep being finished.
Where is he?
I don't know if this is better or not.
I can't tell.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know which weapon is better.
I can't tell.
Maybe this one because I break it faster.
I break it faster.
Okay, focus.
Jesus Christ, I'm trying to like...
I can't parry with this stuff.
I'm so bad at parrying with the spear.
I don't know how to parry with spear.
I'm better parrying with...
Jesus!
I don't know how to parry with the spear.
Okay.
He's gonna grab me.
He was gonna grab me.
Alright.
Yes.
Oh my god, I don't know how to do it.
I'm not gonna try.
Okay.
He has to run into this.
Fuck!
See, I don't know how to do it!
Okay.
I don't know how to parry with my spear!
I don't know!
I'm so bad at it!
Oh no.
Jesus Christ.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, nice!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Ah!
Please get near this.
No!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I jumped!
People told me to jump!
I don't jump!
You mean they lied?!
Oh my god.
I got lied to.
I got fed bad intel.
They told me to just jump.
Just jump, forehead.
I'm restarting this one.
They lie.
They're like, just jump!
Just jump!
Just fucking jump!
Just jump, guys!
That's all you have to do!
Just jump, doki!
Jesus Christ.
Jesus!
I hate this look.
Okay.
It's not over yet.
Fucking hell.
I hate this guy.
I hate him.
I hate him!
God, please!
I don't want to be finished!
Please!
Jesus!
Ah!
Oh my god, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I run.
Oh my god, I run.
I'm so mad.
Why is he so strong?
Why is he...
I don't...
I don't want to be finished!
Oh my god.
The tornado is so strong though.
What do you fucking have?
It breaks the thing easier for me.
It helps me break the thing.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
I hate this.
I'm...
Alright, end me.
End me.
End me!
This is like the worst fight ever.
It sucks because I'm like locked into like an easy...
He has like one easy fucking damage on me.
That's the worst part.
Okay, what if... Okay, is there any other gun?
Alright, 218.
No, that is literally my strongest weapon.
Oh my god.
Okay, what if I use this?
What if it's Twin Peaks time?
Maybe I'm just a Twin Peak user.
Maybe that's it.
Oh my god, maybe it's not.
Guys, maybe it's not.
Maybe it's not.
I can't tell.
Okay.
I can't tell if I'm doing better or not.
Oh, I wish Gohan was still here.
I wish I still had more buttons.
I really do.
Oh, fuck!
Fuck!
Oh my god.
No!
The reason why I use the tornado is I break shields so fast.
See, like his shield's almost broken already.
See, look.
His shield's broken.
It's already broken, so I feel like I have to use the spear.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Whoa!
I feel the same way.
Oh.
I wish my dragoons were still fighting this fight with me.
And instead, they ran away.
I'm so sad they ran away, guys.
I wish my dragoons were still fighting.
Hahaha.
My dragoons ran away.
Guys, why did you run?
Why weren't you there with me?
Hahaha.
Hang on.
Jesus Christ.
I messed it up.
Oh shit.
No!
I thought it was orange!
I thought it was orange.
God, how long am I gonna fight this guy?
Oh my god.
How long am I gonna fight him?
Jesus.
Okay.
I can't.
I can't!
Fuck!
I have to restart.
Okay.
Here we go.
Damn.
My...
Okay.
You sent him in the air.
Oh!
Yeah.
Yeah, no shit.
No shit is looking fucking rough!
Yeah, thanks for telling me that!
Ah!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No!
Oh.
I dodged!
I fucked up the dodge timing!
I fucked it up.
Ah!
I'm full focus now.
Okay, I'm actually full focus now.
Damn.
Come on.
Nice.
I see it.
Fucking whore.
You fucking whore!
Why do you get that attack off?!
Are you serious?!
Ah!
Just end me.
I'm finished.
No!
We are not restarting!
I believe!
Okay.
Restart.
I believe after we restart.
Just hit me once.
Just hit me one more time.
Alright.
We can do this.
We don't need buns.
We don't need musou.
We can do this.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Two.
Oh, I see you.
Easy.
Are you serious?!
Time to attack.
Ready up.
I see it.
Take that.
Come on.
What?!
That hits me?!
Alright.
It's over.
It was not supposed to hit me there.
Okay.
The timing!
Jesus Christ.
I hate this.
I hate this part because he like softlocked me into that.
It's actually not fair.
So I'm like taking a free hit almost every time.
Time to act.
This is why I use the tornado.
Yeah, that is actually the worst checkpoint I could get.
Here we go.
Time to act.
Time
to attack.
No.
Here we go.
Okay.
Time to turn the tables.
Take this.
With all my might.
Time to attack.
Time to act.
What the?!
That was an accident!
It was actually an accident!
I'm so bad!
A horse!
It was such a good ride!
The horse is binded to my left analog stick.
And I actually pressed it!
If you press the left analog stick, it like activates the horse.
Oh my god, that was such a good fucking ride!
Jesus Christ.
That was actually such a good ride.
If you press down, it like activates it.
That's what happened.
I was like, it was such an intense fight, I actually pressed down.
Okay.
Gotta be quicker.
Time to act.
With all my might.
Ready yourself.
Time to attack.
You're finished.
Time to act.
Time to attack.
Nice.
What the?!
How do you dodge that?!
How do you dodge it?!
I don't understand!
Yes!
I...
Okay.
Time to act.
I don't understand.
I don't understand!
How do you dodge that move?!
I dashed through it!
Oh my god.
You just run?!
You need your ultimate, you just run away?!
Just...
Run or... okay.
This is before he does Musou.
Okay.
Save your Musou to fight his... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I have to...
I worked so hard to...
Do we actually have to restart?!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll do one more attempt.
If we can't do it on this attempt, I'm...
I was so fucking... I played the fucking best out of my...
I actually played so well too.
That's the worst part.
I played so...
Like, I literally played like the best I've ever played.
And like...
I thought I just had to... Oh my god.
I played the best I could ever play there.
It was actually crazy how well...
Okay.
Oh shit, I forgot.
Whoops.
I forgot that he's already shield broken.
I'm so...
I've already lost my groove there.
It's too late.
Alright, we restart.
Let's restart.
Oh my god.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
It's too late.
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know where... Okay, when did I have Musou?
Okay.
Does it show when I have Musou?
Oh, I don't.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll start here.
We'll start here.
Oh my god.
I believe.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Guys.
I don't think I should have started from the beginning, guys.
Guys, I might have thrown by starting from the beginning.
I...
I forgot.
Okay.
I don't know how I got... Okay, guys.
Let's start from the beginning beginning.
Okay, guys.
The buttons are back?
Maybe.
Okay, guys.
Let's start from the beginning beginning.
I might have fucked up by saying let's start all the way back from the beginning.
Mistakes were actually made.
Oh my god.
Mistakes were actually made, guys.
I don't know how to build my Musou.
Okay, we gotta build Musou over here.
I'm gonna try and build my Musou from these guys.
If I can get to... If he can leave me alone.
I'll build Musou off the regular people real quick, guys.
Oh my god.
I'll let Nobu fight the others.
I need Musou.
Where are they?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Why me?
I'm so mad.
Why is it always me?
Why is it... Okay, my one troop.
Okay.
Okay, I need... I need... I need bread.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Guys, I should not have started from the beginning.
I may have fucked up by starting from the beginning.
I definitely fucked up there.
I thought it was like, use boost, so I was like, okay.
No!
I was trying to die!
It was an accident.
I didn't want to use Musou.
I didn't want to use it.
Jesus Christ, we have to restart.
We gotta restart.
Unless...
Oh, nope.
Did I block?
Nope.
Alright, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
Oh.
Alright, how much was this part?
Alright, nope, we go back, we go further.
It softlocks.
It softlocks, oh my, every time!
It softlocks me in an area where he has like the red ability.
It's actually fucked up.
It's so fucked up!
How does it not?
When you're happy and he has the red abilities like oh my I hate that I hate that like every I'm backing further away.
I'm backing further away.
I can't I hate that it soft locks me to like where he has a power
Oh my god I'm back kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me Kill me where we started where we starting kill this
This is actually not fair this is okay kill me kill me kill me kill me kill me it's not fair It's not fair.
Just- just end this.
End this.
Just end this.
This is not fair.
Okay.
There we go.
All right, I'm full focusing here.
Fucking hell.
Looking rough.
Oh,
fucking hell.
Jesus Christ.
That will have no effect on me.
Surely you are not spent yet.
Now it's my turn.
This just sucks.
I forgot to recharge my musou.
I need to- I need to kill people around me.
I forgot about that.
I forgot about like- the whole point was to get musou.
Jesus Christ!
I forgot how to dodge for a second there.
Fuck.
Okay.
Jesus Christ!
Okay, I need to get- I actually need bread.
Okay, John Fei might die here though.
Okay.
Hmm.
Whoa, whoa,
whoa.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
I have the rage musou now.
I gotta make sure I use it for just that fight.
Jesus Christ.
Fuck.
We need a- this is my last buns.
Okay, my last two.
Okay.
That was an accident.
I didn't mean to jump.
Okay.
Time to attack.
Take this!
I'll show you how much better I am.
Time to act.
I see it.
Jesus Christ.
Time to act.
Come on!
I'm so focused right now.
Oh my god!
Of course, of course.
I jinxed myself.
I jinxed myself the moment I say that.
No!
Every time the horse fucks me over!
The horse actually fucks me over.
I'm so sad.
I need to unbind the horse.
It's actually throwing me off.
Oh my god.
Finish.
All right, I'm unbinding the horse.
I'm unbinding the horse.
I can't.
I actually can't.
Where's the horse?
Where the fuck is the horse?
Where is it?
Okay, get the rid of the horse.
Get rid of the horse.
Get unassigned.
Um, I don't fucking know.
Count.
Ah, fuck.
Okay.
What do I put the horse on?
Here, give me that horse.
I don't fucking know.
Oh my god.
It won't.
Oh my god, it won't.
Oh my god, I can't.
I... oh my god.
Guys, I accidentally softlocked the horse.
I'm softlocked.
It wouldn't let me... it wouldn't let me change.
It wouldn't let...
I can't change it.
Oh, I got stuck.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, okay, it's enter.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Get me out!
I'm pressing buttons.
It won't let me change.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
All right.
What was P?
I don't know.
Okay.
P. All right, I don't know where P was.
I'll show you.
Okay.
I swear to fucking god.
It's not over yet.
Take a deep breath.
I'm taking a deep breath.
Oh my god, I fucking hate this.
I hate him.
I hate Lu Bu.
Why is he like this?
And I have to go through the arrows.
Okay.
Of course, I have to go through the stupid arrows.
The stupid fucking arrows of all things.
I always get locked in.
Okay.
Okay, I fucked it up.
I already fucked it up.
Okay, I'm going in with less HP too.
That's the worst part.
I'm going in.
But at least I have my Musou.
I have my Musou though.
I have my Musou, but I'm going in with less HP.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm locking in.
Okay.
He's back!
I didn't even...
Okay.
Get him out.
Get this horse out of here.
Get him out of here.
Bind him somewhere else.
Bind him.
I swear.
Give me something else.
I swear to god.
Here.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
There we go.
I'm... I can't.
Restart.
Oh, restart.
Alright, locked in.
Okay.
The horse did everything.
The horse ruined everything.
Okay.
Whoa.
What?
Okay, fine.
Fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
Fine, that's fine.
Oh my god.
No!
I timed it wrong!
All of this has to do with timing!
Yeah.
Just have to get him over to the safe.
He put me in that fucking hole!
Oh my god, you fucker!
I hate him.
I hate him so much!
Bitch.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fine.
Yeah.
How boring.
Fine.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
No.
What's that?
No!
Yes!
Please!
Oh my god.
No!
Get him out of the lobby!
Get him out of my fucking...
After three years!
Oh my god, after fucking three years.
Oh my god.
Why are they here?
They did nothing!
They died when he was like, barely hurt!
What did they do?
What did these guys do?
They did nothing!
I can't believe they took my credit!
I'm so tired.
This cutscene is so cool, but I'm so tired.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Where am
I in this cutscene?
Where am I?
After every scene!
What do you mean I'm not there?
I did so much!
Where am I?
I just want to be in the cutscene!
I don't even get the bare minimum!
I'm so sad, I'm so sad.
This is robbery.
This is robbery, what the fuck did Olufe do?
Can I at least get some validations and chat?
You guys know I was part of it, right?
You guys know I did all the...
You guys saw it, right?
You guys saw me do everything, right?
I was so close!
I don't even get like...
I don't even get like one visual in there.
They actually erased me from the cutscene.
And so fucked up.
George, I got zero screen time.
I've been fighting Lu Bu.
I was so close to crashing out, guys.
You don't understand.
That was such a...
Okay, confession.
After Dynasty Warriors, I was going to play Elder Ring.
But like, after that fight, I'm playing something more chill after Dynasty Warriors.
I can't, guys.
I'm there.
I'm not doing Elder Ring right after Dynasty Warriors.
That...
Oh, I can't do that again right now.
I need to rest.
Oh my god.
That Lu Bu fight was fucking crazy.
I hate Lu Bu now.
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
T-Pose, thank you for the super chat.
And no one remembered us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is all Lu Bu's fault.
Estero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so sick, girl.
Punchtop, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats, Doki.
You have chained Lu Bu up and brought him to his knee.
And now he knows what to do for you since you conquered him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why was that fuck so hard?
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
Lu Bu perished in Xiapi.
Cao Cao returned to the city of Xu.
Accompanied by Lu Bei.
For impregnating you after the general host bar.
Bro, they just rewrote me out of history.
I don't even know how long I fought him.
What?
Well,
there I am.
I finally made my appearance.
There you are.
Lord Xu Huang.
I had heard that you would serve Lord Cao Cao.
So I came to give you my greetings.
I don't play Dynasty Warriors.
I was not expecting fucking a swords game.
You were in a situation similar to my own, were you not?
Lord Xu Huang.
If I may ask, how do you serve two lords without any qualms?
Saying I have no qualms would be a lie.
But so would denying my wish to pursue my path as a warrior.
Even as an enemy, I was astounded by how you fought in Xiapi.
Fighting beside you would truly be a blessing.
I can only hope that I may follow in your footsteps as a great warrior.
Lord Guan Yu.
Lord Zhen Liao.
I ask you both for your guidance.
So you would follow me just as I followed Lord Lu Yi Bu?
I'm not like... I'm not like registering anything in this conversation right now.
I'm like disassociating from that Lu Yi Bu fight.
I'm so disassociated right now.
That fucking fight was actually... I actually had to start parrying.
I had to fucking parry to fucking beat him.
Like... even when I fought against... what was it?
The orphan guy?
The orphan guy in Bloodborne?
I didn't even learn to parry in Bloodborne to kill Orphan of Cause.
I had to learn to parry to fucking kill Lu Bu.
That's like how fucked up it was.
I actually had to learn how to parry to fight Lu Bu.
Like I got away with zero parries on Orphan of Cause.
If you look around...
If you look around, you can see a bot of me killing Orphan of Cause with zero parries.
And then I had to learn how to parry in this game.
Oh my god.
If I didn't have to fight Lu Bu, I could go for like two to three hours.
That took up the rest of my day.
I'm done.
I can't.
That is where I'm gonna call for today.
Call me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Was it worth the... I don't know.
I just hope there's no one that's stronger.
There's no way there's anyone that's harder than this.
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe there's a harder boss fight than this.
That was actually painful.
I barely did any damage too.
That's the worst part.
I was doing little fucking dots.
At least in Orphan of Cause, I was doing a lot of damage per swing.
I was doing fucking toothpick damage on him.
I swear to god.
The dragon's treasure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To get red hair, you need to defeat Lu Bu using no items, no buttons at the highest tip.
Bro, I gotta just eat the horse.
Let the fucking horse die.
I don't need the red hair.
I don't fucking... I'm not doing that.
It took me six hours.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, can I get some validation in chat?
At least have you guys remembered me killing Lu Bu?
Guys, you guys were all there, right?
You guys saw me kill Lu Bu, right?
Can I have some validation?
Oh my god.
I was so angry.
I was so angry during that fight.
It was so bullshit.
The worst part is that he kept...
He kept, like, soft... He was trying to soft lock me too.
I think that was the worst part.
When, like, every time I restart, I get soft locked into a red attack.
Like, it doesn't matter where.
It didn't matter where.
That fight was so bullshit.
I do have no heals on the last checkpoint too.
Have you ever heard of one guy from Shen Yang?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lord Kuro says thank you for the super chat.
Lu Bu was defeated by Doki Hu.
Oh my god.
NotSoDeadPool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lu Hu, I didn't see anything.
Can you try again?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Ever have a Chinese warlord hold you down with his bare hands?
Oh my god.
When he come at the horse.
The fucking horse.
I swear to god, I kept getting fucked over by the horse.
Let me fix my horse real quick.
Actually, you know what?
I'm gonna put it on here.
I think it actually is better if I put it over there.
Alright.
JR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
I'm exhausted.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching me crash out on Lu Bu.
Oh my god, I'm so over this guy.
Okay, I'm gonna go rest now.
It was a long stream.
I played Dynasty Warriors for almost 7 hours.
It was 7 hours of hell.
Well, no.
It was like 5 hours of joy and then 2 hours of hell.
The laugh.
2 hours of absolute hell.
I was stuck in the cage with Lu Bu.
Anyways, I'm gonna call it here.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!